Hello everyone and we have some unbelievably exciting news for you all. Tom, if anything, you are underselling it because this is truly spectacular. On the 4th and 5th of July this year, we are going to be hosting the inaugural. Rest is History Festival. Out of all places, Hampton Court Palace. And crucially, this is just for the people who mean most to us. That is the members of the Rest is History Club. Tom, am I right?
大家好，我们有一个令人难以置信的激动人心的消息要告诉大家。汤姆，如果你说得太轻描淡写了，因为这简直太壮观了。今年7月4日和5日，我们将举办首届“历史就是历史”节（Rest is History Festival）。地点就在汉普顿宫。最重要的是，这仅针对对我们意义最重大的人，也就是“历史就是历史”俱乐部的成员。汤姆，我说得对吗？
You are so right, Dominic. So if you want to access tickets for the festival, then you will need to become a member of the Restless History Club, which is so easy to do. All you have to do is go to therestishistory.com and it's a matter of seconds. Okay, so remember, by becoming a member of the Restis History Club, you will be able to enter that much prized ballot for tickets to this thrilling festival. But of course, on top of that, you'll get all our episodes ad free. You will get early access to our epic series. will get weekly bonus episodes. You will get access to our exciting new exclusive mini-series. Most of all, you'll get an entree to our much-love chat community and many more such exciting
你说得太对了，多米尼克。所以，如果你想获得音乐节的门票，你需要成为“历史就是历史”俱乐部的会员，这非常简单。你只需要访问therestishistory.com，几秒钟就能搞定。好的，请记住，成为“历史就是历史”俱乐部的会员，你将有机会参加那场备受期待的音乐节门票抽签。当然，除此之外，你还可以免广告收听我们所有的节目。你将获得我们史诗系列节目的抢先收听权，获得每周的额外剧集，还可以收听我们令人兴奋的全新独家迷你系列节目。最重要的是，你将进入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，以及更多令人兴奋的
benefits. So if you want guaranteed access to two tickets, you can join the very top tier of the club and become an Athelstan. You will also get the exclusive opportunity to upgrade to a VIP ticket, which includes a range of special perks including, and this is so exciting, unlimited food and unlimited drink. So go to the restishistory.com and sign up immediately. It is going to be the most extraordinary weekend. There'll be talks, there will be thrilling special guests, there will be historically themed music, there'll be all kinds of treats, there'll be all kinds of action, there might even be some battles, but above all all all It'll be a time for friendship to get to know your fellow members and to get to know Tom and me in a very, very special place, Hampton Court Palace.
福利。所以，如果你想确保获得两张门票，你可以加入俱乐部最高等级，成为一名“埃塞尔斯坦”（Athelstan）。你还将获得升级为VIP门票的独家机会，其中包括一系列特别礼遇，包括——这太令人兴奋了——无限量的食物和饮料。所以，请立即前往therestishistory.com注册。这将是一个非凡的周末。届时会有讲座、激动人心的特邀嘉宾、历史主题音乐、各种各样的款待、各种各样的活动，甚至可能还有一些战斗，但最重要的是，这将是一个友谊的时刻，让你结识其他成员，并在一个非常、非常特别的地方——汉普顿宫，结识汤姆和我。
And I know that I speak for Dominic as well as for myself when I say, we cannot wait to see you there. President Carlo looked at me. I'd like to see you Colonel Beckwith before you leave. It was quiet in the room. He walked over and stood in front of me. I want to ask you to do two things for me. Sir, all you got to do is name them. I want you, before you leave for Iran, to assemble all of your force,
我知道我代表多米尼克也代表我自己说，我们迫不及待地想在那里见到你们。卡洛总统看着我。他说：“贝克威斯上校，在你离开之前，我想见你。”房间里很安静。他走过来，站在我面前。“我想请你为我做两件事。”“长官，你尽管吩咐。”“我希望你在去伊朗之前，召集你所有的部队，
and when you think it's appropriate, give them a message from me. Tell them that in the event this operation failed. for whatever reason, the fault will not be theirs. It will be mine. Sir, I give you my word I will do that. The second thing is, if any American is killed, hostage or Delta Force, and if it is possible, as long as it doesn't jeopardize the life of someone else, you bring that body back. Sir, if you've gone over my record, you know I'm that kind of man.
当你认为合适的时候，替我传达一个信息。告诉他们，如果这次行动因为任何原因失败了，那不是他们的错，而是我的错。”“长官，我向你保证，我会这么做的。”“第二件事是，如果有任何美国人牺牲，无论是人质还是三角洲部队成员，如果可能的话，只要不危及他人的生命，你要把遗体带回来。”“长官，如果你看过我的档案，你就知道我是那种人。”
So that was Colonel Charlie Beckwith, Mighty Warrior, founder of the US Special Forces Unit Delta Force. And he was recalling a meeting that he had with President Jimmy Carter on the 16th of April 1980. They met in the White House Situation Room to finalize the plans for one of the most daring military operations in American history. And this was a plan to rescue the 52 Americans who were being kept hostage in the center of Tehran and to get them out of Iran or Iran to safety. And Dominic, I think both men come out of that meeting very well. They do. So Skeletor and Boss Hogg from the Dukes of Hacet in that reading. It's some, I mean, you get the sense, you know, the incredible courage required to undertake what is going to be a mad operation.
这就是查理·贝克威斯上校，伟大的战士，美国特种部队“三角洲部队”的创始人。他正在回忆1980年4月16日他与吉米·卡特总统的一次会面。他们在白宫战情室会面，敲定了美国历史上最大胆的军事行动之一的计划。这是一个营救被扣押在德黑兰市中心的52名美国人，并将他们安全撤出伊朗的计划。多米尼克，我认为这两位在这次会面中表现得都非常好。确实。在那段阅读中，他们就像《杜克兄弟》里的骷髅头和霍格老板。我的意思是，你能感受到执行这一疯狂行动所需的惊人勇气。
Yes. But also Carter's concern. Yeah. You know, I mean, it's obviously causing him immense kind of moral anguish, isn't it, the whole prospect of it? It is, but he's doing the right thing. And he really impressed Colonel Beckwith. And he said, you know, if it goes wrong, it's on me. And then he makes this last request, you bring that body back. and I've got a terrible spoiler. They don't. That's the one thing they don't do is bring the bodies back. But I just wanted to say that because this is an episode that famously kind of dooms Carter's presidency. I mean, a spoiler alert.
是的。但卡特的担忧也是。你知道，这显然给他带来了巨大的道德痛苦，不是吗？整个前景都是如此。确实，但他做的是正确的事。他给贝克威斯上校留下了深刻的印象。他说，如果出了差错，责任由我承担。然后他提出了最后一个要求，把遗体带回来。我有一个糟糕的剧透。他们没有。他们唯一没做到的就是把遗体带回来。但我只是想提一下，因为这一集被公认为注定了卡特总统任期的失败。我是说，剧透预警。
Yeah. But actually, I think he comes out of this pretty impressively. This last episode of our series about the Iranian Revolution and the American reaction to it, I mean, it's sort of the tragedy of Jimmy Carter, really, because we've had some fun with him and his failure to pursue the peanut diplomacy that the situation called for in previous episodes. Aggressive approach to rabbits, all kinds of things
是的。但实际上，我认为他在这件事上的表现相当令人印象深刻。这是我们关于伊朗革命及美国反应系列节目的最后一集，这其实算是吉米·卡特的悲剧，因为在之前的剧集中，我们拿他和他在外交上未能采取局势所要求的“花生外交”开了一些玩笑。对兔子的激进态度，各种各样的事情
go wrong. But in this episode, yeah, he's so unlucky. I mean, he's just unbelievably unlucky. So anyway, this is the climax of our series on this tangled relationship between the United States and Iran at the end of the 70s. So as we said, we'll be talking about Delta Forces' attempt to rescue the hostages and what it meant for the presidential
都出了差错。但在这一集中，是的，他太倒霉了。我的意思是，他简直倒霉透顶。总之，这是我们关于70年代末美国与伊朗之间纠葛关系的系列节目的高潮。正如我们所说，我们将讨论三角洲部队营救人质的尝试，以及它对吉米·卡特与“历史就是历史”的老朋友罗纳德·威尔逊·里根之间的总统
election between Jimmy Carter and old associate of the rest is history, Ronald Wilson Reagan. And we'll be talking about the fate of the American hostages in Tehran, and we'll also be talking about what happened to the Iranian Revolutionary regime. Well, as we record this, Dominic,
选举意味着什么。我们将讨论德黑兰美国人质的命运，也将讨论伊朗革命政权的结局。好吧，多米尼克，在我们录制这期节目时，
we're not absolutely certain what's going to happen to the Iranian Revolutionary regime. Right, who right now are embroidered in all these street protests and repression and whatnot and President Trump making his threats. So let's remind ourselves a little bit of the context. Revolution had broken out Iran at the turn of 1978. The Shah fled a year later, January, 1979.
我们并不完全确定伊朗革命政权会发生什么。没错，他们现在正陷入各种街头抗议、镇压等等之中，特朗普总统也在发出威胁。所以让我们回顾一下背景。1978年之交，伊朗爆发了革命。一年后，即1979年1月，国王逃亡。
The Ayatala Khomeini returned in triumph from exile. There's chaos in the streets, but he has started to lay the foundations for his new state based on this idea of kind of clerical guardianship. Yeah, it's kind of ruled by jurists, isn't it? Yes. It's actually a bit like Britain. Tom is only moments away from a rant about unelected judges, clearly.
霍梅尼从流亡中凯旋归来。街头一片混乱，但他已经开始为他的新国家奠定基础，基于这种“教士监护”的理念。是的，这有点像法学家统治，不是吗？是的。这实际上有点像英国。汤姆离吐槽那些未经选举产生的法官只有几分钟的路程了，很明显。
Nadine Dorris joins the rest is history. It's a little bit of political satire there, which I hope people enjoy. There's a space for you on Liz Truss's podcast, Tom, if you want to join that particular show. So anyway, Carter agreed to admit the Shard in New York for cancer treatment. A student militants stormed the U.S. Embassy on the 4th of November 1979. They took the staff hostage. They eventually released the black and female hostages, and that left 52 Americans in captivity. And although Khomeini probably didn't know about the embassy takeover,
娜丁·多里斯加入了“历史就是历史”。这有一点政治讽刺，希望大家喜欢。汤姆，如果你想参加那个节目，利兹·特拉斯的播客里有你的位置。总之，卡特同意让国王去纽约接受癌症治疗。1979年11月4日，学生激进分子冲进了美国大使馆。他们扣押了工作人员作为人质。他们最终释放了黑人和女性人质，留下了52名美国人被囚禁。虽然霍梅尼可能并不知道大使馆被占领的事，
and this was never part of the plan, the issue becomes so useful to him politically that he decides to hang on to the captives and this becomes this great personal duel between him and Jimmy Carter. So let's get to the beginning of 1980. The hostages have been in captivity for weeks. They're having a terrible time.
这从来都不是计划的一部分，但这个问题在政治上对他来说太有用了，以至于他决定扣住这些人质，这成了他与吉米·卡特之间的一场伟大的个人决斗。让我们回到1980年初。人质已经被囚禁了数周。他们过得很惨。
They're exhausted, they're hungry, they're frightened, all of this. Important point, they have not yet been split up and put in prisons around Tehran. They're still at the United States. Embassy, the den of spies, as the Iranians. now call it. And are they starting to do all those kind of frescoes on the walls showing Uncle Sam as a
他们精疲力竭、饥肠辘辘、惊恐万状，所有这些。重要的一点是，他们还没有被分开并关进德黑兰各地的监狱。他们仍然被关在美国大使馆，也就是伊朗人现在所说的“间谍巢穴”。他们是不是开始在墙上画那些把山姆大叔画成
skeleton and all of that kind of thing? Exactly. And there were huge crowds and we were talking last time about the exciting hats, the souvenir hats that the Iranians are selling. Yes. So globally the impact of the revolution and the catastrophic impact on the oil industry is rippling through the world economy. So the United States has tipped into recession in January 1980, and the presidential campaign has got underway. So on the one hand, you have the former governor of California, the champion of the conservatives, Ronald Reagan. And he builds an early lead in the Republican primaries. He's pretty obviously going to be the Republican candidates. And he's promising to roll back the federal state and to take a much harder line in the Cold War. And indeed,
骷髅之类的壁画了？没错。当时有大量人群，我们上次谈到了伊朗人正在兜售的那些令人兴奋的纪念品帽子。是的。所以，革命的全球影响以及对石油工业的灾难性影响正在波及世界经济。因此，美国在1980年1月陷入了衰退，总统竞选已经开始。一方面，你有前加州州长、保守派的捍卫者罗纳德·里根。他在共和党初选中建立了早期领先优势。他显然会成为共和党候选人。他承诺缩减联邦政府规模，并在冷战中采取更强硬的立场。事实上，
and this is a direct quote, to make America great again. So not the last time we'll hear that particular message. Now, for the Democrats, Jimmy Carter was in terrible trouble, really, domestically, because the economy had tanked and he was unnecessarily wearing cardigans and giving speeches about national spiritual crises and so on. Can I just ask, has he introduced oil sanctions against Iran? No, not yet. So the sanctions will come later. As we'll see, he's taking a deliberately soft lying because he thinks that will get the hostages back. So Carter's handlers had said to him, well, actually, this, um, hostage crisis could work in your favour because people might rally around the flag.
这是一句直接引语，“让美国再次伟大”。所以这不会是我们最后一次听到这个特定的信息。现在，对于民主党来说，吉米·卡特确实陷入了可怕的困境，因为经济崩溃了，他还在不必要地穿着开襟羊毛衫，发表关于国家精神危机的演讲等等。我能问一下，他是否对伊朗实施了石油制裁？不，还没有。所以制裁是后来才有的。正如我们将看到的，他故意采取软弱的路线，因为他认为这样能让人质获释。所以卡特的助手们曾对他说，其实，这个
They might rally to you, the sitting president, rather than to the challenger from the liberal side who is Ted Kennedy. Chapo-Quiddick's Ted Kennedy. And actually, they're right. In the early primaries, Carter wipes the floor with Ted Kennedy, partly because people keep saying to Ted Kennedy, are you not the bloke who drowned that woman? Like, you can't run for president if you've done that. But also, Ted Kennedy turns out to be a terrible candidate.
人质危机可能对你有利，因为人们可能会团结在旗帜周围。他们可能会团结在你这位现任总统周围，而不是团结在来自自由派的挑战者泰德·肯尼迪身边。查帕奎迪克的泰德·肯尼迪。事实上，他们是对的。在早期的初选中，卡特横扫了泰德·肯尼迪，部分原因是人们不断问泰德·肯尼迪：“你不是那个淹死女人的家伙吗？你做过那种事怎么能竞选总统呢？”而且，泰德·肯尼迪也被证明是一个糟糕的候选人。
So when they ask him, he's asked in an interview, why would you like to be president? and he gives this incredibly rambling answer for about 20 minutes. He doesn't have a reason. He's not like David Cameron. Remember how his answer? I think I'd be quite good at it. Because I'd be good at it. But why didn't he just say, I'm a Kennedy?
所以当他们在采访中问他，你为什么想当总统时？他给出了一个长达20分钟的极其冗长的回答。他没有理由。他不像大卫·卡梅伦。还记得他的回答吗？“我想我会做得很好。”“因为我会做得很好。”但他为什么不直接说，“我是肯尼迪”？
Yes. I think because people are a bit sick of Canada-ness by this point, to be honest with you. Now, abroad, Carter is reinventing himself as a bit of a hawk as well. So previously, he'd all been, you know, about sort of peace and love in 1976. But now the Soviet Union has invaded Afghanistan. He's reinvented himself as Harry Truman, one of the founders of NATO. So he's basically gone to Congress. He said, I want lots more money for defence.
是的。老实说，我认为是因为人们此时对“肯尼迪式”的东西有点厌倦了。现在，在国外，卡特也在把自己重塑为一个鹰派。之前，他在1976年时一直谈论的是和平与爱。但现在苏联入侵了阿富汗。他把自己重塑成了哈里·杜鲁门，北约的创始人之一。所以他基本上去了国会。他说，我需要更多的国防预算。
I'm going to punish the Russians with a boycott of the Moscow Olympics. I'll teach him. Well, that didn't teach them. And actually, the result was that Alan Wells, a Britain, won the 100-metre sprint for the first time in decades. Yeah, Sebastian Coe and Steve Avet and Daly Thompson. So great scenes. And it's the Americans who missed out. The Americans, I think the Germans, the West Germans, the Canadian.
我要通过抵制莫斯科奥运会来惩罚俄罗斯人。我会教训他们的。好吧，那并没有教训到他们。事实上，结果是英国的艾伦·威尔斯几十年来首次赢得了100米短跑冠军。是的，塞巴斯蒂安·科、史蒂夫·奥维特和戴利·汤普森。场面太棒了。而错失机会的是美国人。美国人，我想德国人、西德人、加拿大人
and the Japanese didn't go, and a load of other countries, but we went. Although Mrs. Satcher didn't want us to go. She didn't want us to go and the athletes defied her. Yeah. Yeah. So there you go. And he's also, Carter, here's a bit of irony, he's asked Congress for Massive Military Aid to Pakistan and he's stepped up CIA support for the Majahadeen in Afghanistan.
和日本人都没有去，还有很多其他国家，但我们去了。尽管撒切尔夫人不想让我们去。她不想让我们去，但运动员们违抗了她。是的。是的。所以就是这样。而且卡特还有一个讽刺的地方，他要求国会向巴基斯坦提供大规模军事援助，并加强了中情局对阿富汗圣战者的支持。
Yeah. These noble fighters for freedom. Right. Yeah. So this is the era. Have you seen the Bond film, The Living Daylights, with Timothy Dalton? Yeah. They're the heroes of that film.
是的。这些高尚的自由战士。没错。是的。所以这就是那个时代。你看过蒂莫西·道尔顿主演的邦德电影《黎明生机》吗？是的。他们是那部电影里的英雄。
One of them is played by Art Malick, and he turns out he went to Cambridge or something like that, or Oxford, I can't remember which. Anyway, none of this produces instant results in Iran. And the problem for Carter is he has made the hostage crisis now the absolute kind of fulcrum, the test of his presidency. But he couldn't really do anything else, could he? I mean, if you've got, you've had your diplomats kidnapped and they're on national news. I mean, you can't just ignore it and pretend it's not happening. Yeah, I guess so. I mean, that's what Kennedy would do, of course.
其中一个由阿特·马利克饰演，结果发现他去了剑桥还是什么地方，或者是牛津，我不记得了。总之，这些在伊朗都没有产生立竿见影的效果。卡特的问题在于，他现在已经把人质危机变成了他总统任期的绝对支点和考验。但他真的没法做别的，不是吗？我的意思是，如果你的外交官被绑架了，而且他们上了全国新闻。我的意思是，你不能只是无视它，假装它没发生。是的，我想也是。我的意思是，那当然是肯尼迪会做的事。
nothing to see. Yeah. Kennedy would swim back to his hotel, put on a change of clothes. Put on a spiffy outfit. Yeah. But Carter has personalised it. He's cancelled all his trips. He's cancelled meetings.
“没什么可看的。”是的。肯尼迪会游回他的酒店，换身衣服。穿上一套时髦的行头。是的。但卡特把它个人化了。他取消了所有的行程。他取消了会议。
He's made a huge hullabaloo of going to prayer meetings and so on. Now, at first, he thinks when the Soviets invade Afghanistan, he thinks, well, this will actually work out very well for me. Because if there's one thing the Iranians hate, you know, as much as... Americans, they hate godless Russian communists. So maybe if I take a restrained line towards Tehran, if I don't impose sanctions, which he doesn't, this will do the trick. Basically, the Soviet Union will scare the Ayatollahs into my embrace. But the problem is, you know, he's still hoping that they will negotiate, but it's not clear to him still whom he's meant to be
他大张旗鼓地去参加祈祷会等等。起初，当苏联入侵阿富汗时，他认为，好吧，这对我来说其实会很有效。因为如果说伊朗人有什么像讨厌美国人一样讨厌的东西，那就是无神论的俄罗斯共产主义者。所以也许如果我对德黑兰采取克制路线，如果我不实施制裁——他确实没实施——这就会奏效。基本上，苏联会把阿亚图拉们吓进我的怀抱。但问题是，你知道，他仍然希望他们会谈判，但他仍然不清楚他到底应该
negotiating with. Homini, who is the figurehead of the regime, has said explicitly, you know, he won't give up the hostages. We fight against America until death. We shall not stop fighting until we defeat it. I don't know why I've given him that voice, but I have. Well, he's cast America as the great Satan. And if you're up against the great Satan, you have to keep fighting it, don't you?
和谁谈判。霍梅尼，作为政权的象征，已经明确表示，他不会交出人质。“我们与美国战斗到底。在击败它之前，我们绝不会停止战斗。”我不知道为什么我用了那种声音，但我用了。好吧，他把美国塑造成了“大撒旦”。如果你在对抗“大撒旦”，你就必须继续战斗，不是吗？
Yeah, you can't negotiate with the great Satan. The Americans are hoping that maybe he's just a very loud figurehead. So, for example, he's got a new foreign minister at beginning of 1980 called Sadek Gottbzada. What is it? Gotbzada, Tom. Do you want to keep saying it? No, you got it. Yeah, I got it.
是的，你不能与“大撒旦”谈判。美国人希望他可能只是一个非常吵闹的象征性人物。例如，他在1980年初有一位新的外交部长，名叫萨德克·戈特布扎德。是什么？戈特布扎德，汤姆。你想一直说吗？不，你说了。是的，我说了。
It didn't take a thousand takes, honestly. So this bloke got bizada was a former student activist. He'd been kicked out in the 50s. He'd gone to Georgetown University, so he's American educated. Oh, so a hotbed of radicalism. He had become very close to Khomeini in Paris. He'd been on the flight with him from France. And the Americans say, look at this bloke, this bloke, he's a man we can do business with.
老实说，这没花一千次录制。所以这个叫戈特布扎德的家伙曾是一名学生激进分子。他在50年代被开除。他去了乔治城大学，所以他是受过美国教育的。哦，激进主义的温床。他在巴黎与霍梅尼走得很近。他曾和霍梅尼一起从法国乘飞机回来。美国人说，看看这家伙，这家伙，他是我们可以打交道的人。
He's American-educated, he looks very sort of smart and Western. And actually, they're right. Gottpzada wants to end the hostage crisis because he thinks, quite rightly, this is a gift to the hardliners. It's allowing them to kind of set in the regime further and further down the kind of Islamist road. So how has this American-educated, clean-shaven technocrat come to be foreign minister who's appointed him? At this point, there is an interim government.
他受过美国教育，看起来非常聪明和西化。事实上，他们是对的。戈特布扎德想结束人质危机，因为他认为，非常正确地，这对强硬派来说是一份礼物。这让他们能够进一步将政权推向伊斯兰化的道路。那么，这位受过美国教育、刮得干干净净的技术官僚是如何成为外交部长的？是谁任命他的？此时，有一个临时政府。
under a guy called Bani Sadr, who is, again, slightly more technocratic, more moderate. You know, at this point, remember, the regime is not fully established. There's still an awful lot of jostling for position, not least among the different paramilitary groups on the streets. And, well, we can get massively bogged down at this point, but it's true the Iranian regime from 1979 to the present, that there are always factions, different elements, different elements, within it, reformists, conservatives. And that great tension between the structures of democracy and the structures of Khomeini's religious-focused rule.
在一个叫巴尼萨德尔的人领导下，他同样稍微更技术官僚、更温和一些。你知道，在这一点上，请记住，政权还没有完全建立。街头各准军事组织之间仍然存在大量的权力争夺。而且，好吧，我们现在可能会陷入困境，但伊朗政权从1979年至今确实存在着不同的派系，不同的元素，改革派、保守派。以及民主结构与霍梅尼以宗教为核心的统治结构之间的巨大张力。
Exactly. So on the one hand, you have Holmeney saying, if you oppose the government, because it's a government deriving its authority from the Quran and the Sharia. So if you oppose it, it's a blasphemy against God. And yet at the same time, you have democratic elections. Yeah. You know, competitive elections. Anyways, for Westerners, it's a very confusing picture.
没错。所以一方面，你有霍梅尼说，如果你反对政府，因为这是一个权力源于《古兰经》和伊斯兰教法的政府。所以如果你反对它，那就是对上帝的亵渎。然而与此同时，你又有民主选举。是的。你知道，竞争性选举。总之，对于西方人来说，这是一幅非常令人困惑的画面。
This boat got Bessada. He works on a deal in early 1980 through Argentine, French, Panamanian intermediaries. At one point, amazingly, in February, Carter's chief of staff, a guy from Georgia called Hamilton Jordan, he goes off to Paris to meet this foreign minister, and he flies to Paris with a wig and false mustache that have been given him by the CIA. It's so brilliant. The CIA have a supply of false wigs and moustaches. Yeah, exactly. It's very kind of the Pink Panther strikes again or something. And it's in Paris. And it's in Paris, exactly. He gets there. He has this meeting. I presume he takes
这个叫戈特布扎德的家伙。他在1980年初通过阿根廷、法国、巴拿马的中间人达成了一项协议。有一次，令人惊讶的是，在二月，卡特的幕僚长，一个来自佐治亚州叫汉密尔顿·乔丹的家伙，他去巴黎会见这位外交部长，他戴着中情局给他的假发和假胡子飞往巴黎。这太精彩了。中情局有一批假发和假胡子。是的，没错。这非常像《粉红豹再次出击》之类的东西。而且是在巴黎。而且是在巴黎，没错。他到了那里。他进行了这次会面。我假设他至少在会面时
the moustache off, or the wig off, at least at the meeting. But actually, this doesn't go anywhere. And the reason it doesn't go anywhere, of course, is that Khomeini has no intention of giving up the hostages. He's not going to give away this brilliant card that allows him to cement his control over the streets. So the weeks go by, the breakthrough never comes. And you can see the result in Jimmy Carter's approval rating. It had shot up to about 50% at the turn of the year as people rallied around the flag. But with every about two weeks or so when they do a new poll, it's down another 4 or 5%. And it's dropping all the time. So by March it's into the 30s, which is very bad for an incumbent president, hoping to win re-election.
摘下了胡子或假发。但实际上，这并没有取得任何进展。当然，它没有取得进展的原因是霍梅尼根本无意交出人质。他不会放弃这张让他能够巩固对街头控制权的绝佳牌。所以几周过去了，突破从未到来。你可以在吉米·卡特的支持率中看到结果。在年初，随着人们团结在旗帜周围，他的支持率一度飙升至50%左右。但每隔两周左右，当他们进行新的民意调查时，它就会下降4%或5%。而且它一直在下降。所以到了三月，它降到了30多，这对一位希望赢得连任的现任总统来说是非常糟糕的。
Presumably this is also because of the recession. So the recession is a massive part of this. But also a perception, I think, of weakness. A perception that Jimmy Carter at this point has what you might call, he's got basically the opposite of the Midas touch. Everything he touches crumbles into dust and it's not really his fault. No, because what credibly can he do? Again, we could
大概这也是因为经济衰退。所以经济衰退是其中的一个重要部分。但我认为还有一种软弱的感知。一种感知，即吉米·卡特此时拥有你可能称之为，他基本上拥有与“点石成金”相反的能力。他所触碰的一切都化为尘土，而且这并不是他的错。不，因为他能做什么呢？同样，我们可以
spend ages talking about this but I think political leadership is about seizing control of a narrative and appearing to be the master of events and also making the most of crises. I mean, you say what can he do? Franklin D. Roosevelt was president in the Great Depression
花很长时间谈论这个，但我认为政治领导力在于掌控叙事，表现得像事件的主宰，并充分利用危机。我的意思是，你说他能做什么？富兰克林·D·罗斯福在经济大萧条时期担任总统，
much worse economically than this and yet he projected an image of vitality and vigor and activism and good cheer that resonated with enough Americans for him to win election after election, even though a lot of what he was doing didn't work out. But he didn't have loads of diplomats who were being paraded every day on the TV stations of a very hostile power. No, he didn't, but if you look at Reagan's time in office, for example, I mean, there was some absolute disaster in Reagan's time in office, not just things like Iran-Contra or economic, you know, borrowing loads of money and stuff. No, I suppose there were hostages in Lebanon, weren't there? There were hostages in Lebanon. There was a massive attack. The Americans were basically kicked out of Lebanon.
经济状况比这糟糕得多，但他展现出了一种活力、精力、行动力和乐观的形象，这引起了足够多美国人的共鸣，使他一次又一次地赢得选举，尽管他所做的事情很多并没有奏效。但他没有那么多外交官每天在一个非常敌对的国家的电视台被游街示众。不，他没有，但如果你看看里根的任期，例如，我的意思是，里根任期内也发生了一些绝对的灾难，不仅仅是像“伊朗门”事件或经济问题，你知道，借了一大笔钱之类的。不，我想黎巴嫩有人质，不是吗？黎巴嫩有人质。发生了一次大规模袭击。美国人基本上被赶出了黎巴嫩。
Reagan was a brilliant performer who was able to turn circumstances to his advantage. Carter, you know, famously, looks. Haggard and Gray. Haggard and Gray. And he doesn't have that Hollywood Sheen. And it may sound like a very trite thing. But as we've said since the very first episodes we ever recorded of this podcast, performance matters enormously. as for Roman emperors as it did for US presidents.
里根是一位出色的表演者，他能够将环境转化为自己的优势。卡特，你知道，众所周知，看起来憔悴而灰暗。憔悴而灰暗。他没有那种好莱坞的光环。这听起来可能是一件非常陈词滥调的事情。但正如我们从录制这个播客的第一集以来所说的那样，表演非常重要。对罗马皇帝如此，对美国总统也一样。
And actually this perception of weakness, by about March, April, even Carter's allies are really running out of patience. So there's an absolutely damning editorial in the Washington Post at the beginning of April. The Washington Post is much more likely to be pro-democrats. Iran, enough. The United States, far from earning respect
事实上，这种软弱的感知，到了三月、四月，甚至卡特的盟友也真的失去了耐心。所以四月初《华盛顿邮报》发表了一篇绝对严厉的社论。《华盛顿邮报》更有可能是亲民主党的。“伊朗，够了。美国，远未赢得尊重
for its restraint and forbearance, is increasingly seen as a country that shrinks from asserting what even its enemies recognized. as a legitimate interest in protecting its diplomats from a mob. So it's interesting. In our lifetime, most of the discourse about the United States has been that it's much too trigger happy, much too swift to intervene militarily, to basically launch airstrikes against people and all of this.
因为它的克制和忍让，反而越来越被视为一个不敢维护其外交官免受暴民侵害的国家，即使是它的敌人也承认这是合法的利益。”所以这很有趣。在我们的一生中，关于美国的大部分讨论都是它太好战了，太快进行军事干预，基本上对人们发动空袭等等。
And here is an instance where the president is taking deliberately a path of restraint because he thinks it will work better. And he's just getting an absolute kicking from his own media and his own people for doing so. And yet, actually, what people don't know is that inside the White House, Carter and his AIDS have been actually talking about, you know, taking more serious action all this time. So in the very first week of the crisis, his national security advisor, I know you're a big fan of this guy's name, aren't you, Tom? Do you want to say his name for everybody?
而这里有一个例子，总统故意走克制之路，因为他认为这样效果更好。结果他却因为这样做而遭到了自己的媒体和自己人民的严厉抨击。然而，实际上，人们不知道的是，在白宫内部，卡特和他的助手们一直都在讨论采取更严肃的行动。所以，在危机的第一周，他的国家安全顾问——我知道你是这个家伙名字的忠实粉丝，对吧，汤姆？你想为大家念一下他的名字吗？
Shabignu Brizinski. Yeah, Zabignev Brzezinski. He's the hardliner, Polish. He has said to Carter, in the first days of the crisis, he was. said, you know, the hostages' lives are really important, but your greater responsibility is to protect the honour and dignity of our country and its foreign policy interests. And Brzezinski says to him, one day, we may have to choose between the hostages and our nation's honour in the world. I mean, that is ultimately the policy that the United States will adopt, isn't it, towards hostage
兹比格涅夫·布热津斯基。是的，兹比格涅夫·布热津斯基。他是强硬派，波兰人。他在危机初期对卡特说，他说，你知道，人质的生命确实很重要，但你更大的责任是保护我们国家的荣誉和尊严及其外交政策利益。布热津斯基对他说，有一天，我们可能不得不在人质和我们国家在世界上的荣誉之间做出选择。我的意思是，这最终是美国将采取的政策，不是吗，针对人质
taking in the Middle East. Yeah. So, I mean, that's why the hostages held by Islamic State were allowed to be killed because there were no negotiations with them. So I guess, I guess it was a lesson learned, maybe. I guess. But, I mean, that's pretty tough for the hostages, right? And also, 52 of them. A lot of hostages taken in one fell swoop. This is slightly different from isolated groups of hostages
在这一地区采取的行动。是的。所以，我的意思是，这就是为什么被伊斯兰国扣押的人质被允许被杀害，因为没有与他们进行谈判。所以我想，我想这是一个学到的教训，也许吧。我想。但是，我的意思是，这对人质来说太艰难了，对吧？而且，52个人。一次性扣押了这么多。这与在较长一段时间内被扣押的孤立人质群体略有不同，我想说。现在，军事选择一直存在。所以一支特遣部队在几天内就开始计划可能的营救任务。我们当然会回到这一点。但卡特的团队也讨论过在伊朗港口布雷、对炼油厂进行空袭，以及轰炸阿巴丹这个巨大的石油综合体，这是世界上最大的石油综合体之一。
that have been taken over a longer period of time, I would say. Now, there have always been military options. So a task force within days had begun planning a possible rescue mission. We shall, of course, come back to this. But Carter's team had also discussed mining Iran's harbors, air strikes against oil refineries and bombing this gigantic oil complex at Aberdan which is one of the biggest oil complexes in the world
卡特实际上对此非常动心，所以他并不像人们通常描绘的那样软弱，但他那贵族气的国务卿赛勒斯·万斯说，匆忙采取行动会非常鲁莽，因为我们会在世界眼中失去道德制高点，而且伊朗人肯定会杀害人质。我的意思是，他们肯定会开始处决。
and Carter had actually been very tempted by this so he's not as weak as he's often painted but his patrician secretary of state Cyrus Vance said this would be very reckless to rush into this because we would lose the moral high ground in the eyes of the world and the Iranians would surely kill the hostages I mean, they would surely start executions.
甚至布热津斯基也说，是的，也许我们应该给外交进程多一点时间。我们不应该匆忙行事。但随着时间的推移，当然，你知道，我们现在到了1980年3月。他们想，好吧，我们永远无法让人质获释。所以3月22日，卡特召集了他的整个国家安全团队到戴维营，讽刺的是，他们是乘直升机去的。他们坐下来，说，好吧，我们该怎么办？参谋长联席会议主席琼斯将军说，好吧，这就是我们一直以来制定的计划。而这个计划背后的家伙就是本集开头的那个人，查理·贝克威斯上校。
And even Brzezinski said, yeah, maybe we should give the diplomatic process a bit more time. We shouldn't rush into this. But over time, of course, you know, we now get to March 1980. And they're thinking, well, we're never going to get these hostages out. So on the 22nd of March, Carter summoned his whole national security team to Camp David, ironically by helicopter. And they sit down and they say, well, what should we do? and the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff, General Jones, says, okay, well, this is the plan that we've been working on all this time. And the bloke behind this plan is the man who opened this episode, Colonel Charlie Beckwith.
他拥有你希望他拥有的那种简历。他曾是佐治亚州全州足球运动员。为了加入驻韩国的美国陆军，他拒绝了绿湾包装工队。多米尼克，我认为这是我们在“历史就是历史”节目中出现过的最美国的一句话。我想毫无疑问是这样。他曾在越南指挥过一支特种部队，胸部中弹，差点丧命。他还——这非常令人高兴。
He has exactly the kind of resume you would want him to have. He was a former Georgia All-State footballer. It turned down the Green Bay Packers in order to join the US Army in Korea. Dominique, I think that is the most American sentence we've ever had on the rest of the I think it undoubtedly is. He had commanded a special forces unit in Vietnam and he'd be hit in the chest and almost killed. He'd also, this is very pleasing.
他在50年代曾作为交换军官在马来亚与英国特种空勤团（SAS）一起服役。同样，他差点死了，我想这次是因为疾病。他非常喜欢SAS。汤姆，我很高兴地说，他喜欢英国。伟人。他说，让我们有一个美国版的，
He'd served as an exchange officer with the SAS in Malaya in the 1950s. And again, he almost died, I think this time of disease. And he absolutely loved the SAS. He liked Britain, Tom, I'm pleased to say. Great man. And he said, let's have an American,
英国人在这方面很出色。为什么我们不建立一个美国版的SAS？疯狂。他被不断地纠缠，不断地纠缠，1977年，他的老板给了他建立“三角洲部队”的绿灯。我的意思是，这名字太棒了。太好了。所以，三角洲部队专门从事反恐和特种作战。
the Brits are brilliant at this. Why don't we have an American SAS? Mad. And he was pestered, and pestered, and in 1977, his bosses gave him the green light to set up Delta Force. I mean, that is such a great name for them. It's so good. So, Delta Force specialized in counterterrorism and special ops.
所以他们是那种人——我知道这对你来说毫无意义，汤姆，但如果你玩《使命召唤》，你就会处于一种“三角洲部队”的心态。所以是三角洲部队把马杜罗从委内瑞拉救出来的，对吧？没错。所以三角洲部队把马杜罗从委内瑞拉救了出来。三角洲部队参与了从巴拿马抓捕曼努埃尔·诺列加的行动。三角洲部队是杀死伊斯兰国领导人阿布·贝克尔·巴格达迪的人，他死得像条狗一样。顺便说一句，那是我的唐纳德·特朗普，以防你感到困惑。是的，他们也杀了他。所以他们有令人印象深刻的记录，如果你喜欢那种东西的话。唐纳德·特朗普说他们在加拉加斯的行动就像电影一样。是的，这就是他们的专长。他们的行动类型，他们专门从事那些随后会成为电影题材的事情，对吧？没错。贝克威斯本人就是一个非常“好莱坞”的角色。他总是留着平头，嘴角总是叼着一支烟。他喜欢烈酒，晚上喜欢喝烈酒。他不处理文书工作。他是一个纯爷们。他亲自挑选了所有人。所以他们都是
So they're the sort of people, I know this will mean nothing to you, Tom, but if you play Call of Duty, you're kind of in a Delta Force kind of mindset. So it's Delta Force that sprung Magero out of Venezuela, right? Right. So Delta Force got Maduroa out of Venezuela. Delta Force were involved in the capture of Manuel Noriega from Panama. And Delta Force were the people who killed the Islamic state leader. Abu Bakar al-Badadi, he died like a dog. That's my Donald Trump, by the way, in case you're baffled. Yeah, they killed him as well. So they've got an impressive track record, if you like that kind of thing. Donald Trump said that their operation in Caracas was like a movie. Yeah, that's what they specialise. him. Their kind of operations, they specialize in things that will then become the subject to movies, right? Exactly. And Beckwith himself is a very Hollywood character. He's always got a crew cut. He's always got a cigarette at the corner of his mouth. He loves a hard liquor, an evening on the hard liquor. He doesn't do his paperwork. He's a man's man. He's chosen them all himself. So they're all
那种饱经风霜、表情冷峻、沉默寡言、值得信赖的人。很像我。是的，就像你，没错。但在1979年，他们从未经过测试，从未做过任何事情。他们刚刚在佐治亚州的森林里完成了第一次重大演习，伊朗人就占领了美国大使馆。贝克威斯听到这个消息时非常兴奋，他立刻赶回布拉格堡开始计划。他的第一次计划尝试是——即使以好莱坞的标准来看，
kind of hard-bitten, grim-faced, taciturn men who can be relied on. Quite like me. Yeah, just like you, exactly. But in 1979, they've never been tested, they've never done anything. They'd just finished their first major exercise in the Forest of Georgia when the Iranian seized the U.S. Embassy. And Beckwith was very excited when he heard this, and he rushed straight back to Fort Bragg to start planning. And his first attempt to plan was, I mean, even by Hollywood standards,
也是疯狂的。三角洲部队将空降到德黑兰东部靠近一条大公路、高速公路的地区。我们将乘降落伞降落到那里。我们将劫持一些卡车。然后我们将开着这些卡车进入德黑兰，冲进大使馆，营救人质。在这一点上，他说，
it was bonkers. Delta Force would be parachuted into an area east of Tehran near this big sort of highway, this motorway. We'll land there by parachute. We'll hijack some trucks. Then we'll drive into Tehran in these trucks, will storm the embassy, rescue the hostages. At this point, he said,
美国轰炸机应该打击伊朗所有的军事基地和炼油厂。德黑兰将陷入彻底的混乱。然后三角洲部队可以杀出德黑兰，再找一些卡车，开400英里到土耳其边境。太棒了。美国！是的，但不幸的是，他的老板们没有那样回应。他们说，你疯了吗？
US bombers should hit all Iran's military bases and oil refinerers. There'll be complete chaos in Tehran. And Delta Force can then fight their way out of Tehran and get some more trucks and drive 400 miles to the Turkish border. Hell yeah. USA! Yeah, but unfortunately, his bosses don't respond like that. They say, are you mad?
到处开车，劫持卡车。你知道，那永远不会奏效。那些只会写文件的官僚。所以他回到了绘图板。当然，在北弗吉尼亚有一个叫“农场”的地方，就像一个中情局基地。在那里，在停机坪上，他们用美纹纸胶带或工程胶带勾勒出了德黑兰美国大使馆的轮廓。他们基本上进行了无休止的演习，在不同的房间里穿梭。所以他们比对自己家还熟悉大使馆。
driving here and there, hijacking trucks. You know, that'll never work. Pen-pushing blotter-dottes. So he goes back to the drawing board. And there's a place called the Farm, of course, in Northern Virginia, which is like a CIA base. And there, on the sort of tarmac, they laid out the outline of the U.S. Embassy in Tehran with masking tape or engineering tape. And they basically did endless drills, kind of working their way around the different rooms. So they know the embassy better than their own homes.
他们认为如果他们能到达大使馆，他们就能杀死守卫并救出人质。问题是他们如何进入德黑兰市中心？这就是解决方案。这很复杂，汤姆。不会有考试的。而且他们实际上只做了其中的一部分，所以不需要考试。
and they reckon if they can get to the embassy, they can kill the guards and get the hostages out. The question is how do they get into the centre of Tehran? And this is the solution. It's quite complicated, Tom. There won't be a test. And they actually only did a bit of it, so it doesn't really need to be a test.
这是第一阶段。八架海军陆战队直升机将从阿曼湾的尼米兹号航空母舰上起飞。他们将飞往南呼罗珊省塔巴斯市附近的一个盐碱沙漠。他们将飞往这个沙漠，飞往他们指定为“沙漠一号”的地方。
So this is stage one. Eight marine helicopters will take off from the aircraft carrier Nymitz in the Gulf of Oman. And they'll fly to this salt desert in South Khorasan near the city of Tabah They'll fly to this desert to a place that they've designated as Desert One.
所以他们降落在“沙漠一号”，在“沙漠一号”，他们将与一些从埃及抵达的大力神运输机（共六架）会合。直升机在航空母舰上，飞机从埃及来，他们将降落在这个沙漠，这些运输机将携带
So they land at Desert One and at Desert One they will rendezvous with some Hercules transport planes, six of them, that have arrived from Egypt. There's the helicopters in the aircraft carrier, there's the planes from Egypt, they'll land at this desert and these transport planes will be carrying
三角洲部队和一些美国游骑兵，大约130人，以及直升机的燃料补给。在“沙漠一号”，他们将为直升机加油。然后三角洲部队将登上直升机，飞往“沙漠二号”，这是德黑兰郊外的另一个沙漠检查站。
Delta Force and some US Rangers so 130 men or so and fuel supplies for the helicopters. And at Desert One they will refuel the helicopters. Then the Delta Force team will get onto the helicopters and they'll fly to Desert 2, which is another desert checkpoint just outside Tehran.
在这里，一个秘密的中情局小组，之前已经渗透进伊朗，将带着一堆卡车在那里等他们。他们将坐上卡车。他们将进入德黑兰。他们将冲进大使馆和伊朗外交部，因为记住还有三个人被困在外交部的餐厅里。所以他们救出所有人。他们是否考虑过扣押，
And here, a secret CIA team, which will have been infiltrated into Iran earlier, will be waiting for them with a load of trucks. They will get in the trucks. They'll go into Tehran. They'll storm the embassy and the Iranian forces. foreign ministry, because remember three blokes are still in the foreign ministry, they're trapped in the dining room of the foreign ministry. So they rescue all of them. Do they contemplate taking,
我不知道，伊朗外交部长作为人质之类的？不，我不这么认为。那是我会做的。是的。我比三角洲部队更无情。更无情，很明显。所以他们会穿过街道去一个足球场，阿姆贾迪足球场，美国直升机将从这个足球场接走他们，飞往德黑兰南部的一个空军基地，一个废弃的空军基地，在此期间，该基地将由一支美国陆军游骑兵小队控制。在这个德黑兰南部的空军基地，他们将被更多的运输机接走，并飞往埃及安全地带。什么可能会出错？我想听众们已经从我对计划的概述中得出了自己的结论，顺便说一句，这只是一个非常简化的版本，
I don't know, the Iranian foreign minister as hostage or something? No, I don't think so. That's what I would have done. Yeah. I'm more ruthless than Delta Force. More ruthless, clearly. So then they'll go across the street to a football stadium, the Amjadir football stadium, and the US helicopters will pick them up from this football stadium and they'll fly them to an air base south of Tehran an abandoned airbase which in the meantime will have been secured by a team of US army rangers and at this air base south of Tehran they'll be picked up by some more transport planes and flown to safety in Egypt. What could possibly go wrong? I think listeners will have drawn their own conclusions from my outline of the plan which by the way is a very simplified version of the
而且极其简化。现实中要复杂得多。我的意思是，它在汤姆·克鲁斯的电影里会奏效，不是吗？会奏效。但只是勉强。但他们可能会在“沙漠一号”、“沙漠二号”被发现。他们的卡车在进入德黑兰的路上可能会被拦下。他们可能会耽误时间，占领大使馆。
And it's extremely simplified. It's much more complicated in reality. I mean, it would work in a Tom Cruise film, wouldn't it? It would. But only just. But they could be spotted at Desert 1, Desert 2. Their trucks could be stopped in the way into Tehran. They might get delayed, capturing the embassy.
如果那里有大量人群，或者有警察，他们甚至可能无法穿过街道到达足球场。好吧，交通。我的意思是，太糟糕了。所有这些。贝克威斯对他的老板们说，听着，我的意思是，你们想怎么抱怨就怎么抱怨。但没有其他计划。没有其他计划。人质不可能通过谈判获释。
They might not even be able to cross the streets, the football stadium if there's a huge crowd there or if there's, you know, police. Well, the traffic. I mean, it's terrible. All of this. And Bekwith says, has said to his bosses, look, I mean, you can winge as much as you like. But there is no other plan. There is no other plan. The hostages aren't getting out by negotiation.
他们甚至可能无法穿过街道，如果那里有大量人群或者有警察的话，比如足球场。交通状况太糟糕了。所有这些。贝克威斯对他的上司说，听着，你们可以随心所欲地抱怨，但没有其他计划了。没有其他计划。人质无法通过谈判获释。
That's pretty clear. And he says, do you know what? It could work. And he has a model in mind, which is the Israeli raid on Entepe in 1976. To remind people about that, 102 largely Israeli hostages were taken in an airline hijacking by Palestinian and I think West German terrorists.
这很清楚。他说，你知道吗？这行得通。他心中有一个蓝图，那就是1976年以色列对恩德培的突袭。提醒一下大家，当时有102名主要是以色列的人质在一次航空劫持事件中被巴勒斯坦和我想是西德的恐怖分子劫持。
And they were flown to Uganda, to Entebbe in Uganda. And people thought it was impossible to get them out. And a load of Israeli commandos flew 2,500 miles, stormed the airfield, stormed the planes, and got almost all of the hostages out alive. They were led by Benjamin Netanyahu's brother, I think. Is that right? I think so. Well.
他们被飞往乌干达，到了乌干达的恩德培。人们认为把他们救出来是不可能的。一大批以色列突击队员飞行了2500英里，突袭了机场，突袭了飞机，几乎让所有人质活着出来了。我想他们是由本雅明·内塔尼亚胡的兄弟领导的。对吗？我想是的。嗯。
And this is the kind of operation, you know, that gave the Israelis in the 70s, this sort of reputation for extraordinary kind of daring and military. sort of prowess, a stunning feat, and Carter and his men think, well, if we could do the same, what a brilliant thing this would be for Carter and for the United States. So even though they can all see the risks, they're all very tempted by it. The one person who's not tempted as Secretary of State Cyrus Vance. He says, this is an insane plan. Things are bound to go wrong, and some of the hostages are bound to be killed. But Carter likes it, and he says start work on reconnaissance. So that was on the 22nd of March.
这就是那种行动，你知道，让以色列人在70年代获得了那种非凡的胆识和军事能力的声誉，一个惊人的壮举，卡特和他的手下想，好吧，如果我们能做到同样的事情，这对卡特和美国来说将是多么辉煌的事情。所以即使他们都能看到风险，他们也都非常动心。唯一不动心的人是国务卿赛勒斯·万斯。他说，这是一个疯狂的计划。事情注定会出错，一些人质注定会被杀害。但卡特喜欢它，他说开始进行侦察工作。所以那是3月22日的事。
Let's move forward a couple of weeks. On the 7th of April, Carter broke off for the, I mean, it's amazing that he hadn't done this before. He broke off diplomatic links with Iran. On the 9th of April, Brazinski, his national security adviser, sent him a note and says, In my view, a carefully planned and boldly executed rescue operation represents the only realistic prospect that the hostages, any of them, will be freed in the foreseeable future. And Brzezinski says, we've pursued a policy of restraint, very un-American, for the last few months, and it's got us a lot of understanding and sympathy, but nothing else, and it's time for us to act.
让我们向前推进几周。4月7日，卡特断绝了——我的意思是，他之前没这样做真是令人惊讶。他断绝了与伊朗的外交关系。4月9日，他的国家安全顾问布热津斯基给他发了一份便条，说：“在我看来，一次精心策划、大胆执行的救援行动是人质在可预见的未来获释的唯一现实前景。”布热津斯基说，过去几个月我们一直奉行克制政策，这非常不美国，这让我们得到了很多理解和同情，但除此之外什么都没有，现在是我们采取行动的时候了。
So two days after that, Carter convenes his National Security Council. Now, crucially, Cyrus Vance, the one doubter, is away on holiday. He's had this long postponed holiday in Florida, which is finally gone on. And Carter has the meeting then when Vance is away, and they all agree, let's go with this plan. Vance gets back a couple of days later and he is horrified and he's outraged they've decided behind his back and he says to Carter
两天后，卡特召集了他的国家安全委员会。现在，关键的是，唯一的怀疑者赛勒斯·万斯去度假了。他终于去休了那个推迟已久的佛罗里达假期。卡特在万斯不在的时候开了会，他们都同意，就执行这个计划。万斯几天后回来，他感到震惊和愤怒，因为他们背着他做出了决定，他对卡特说
if you do this there will be huge reprisals against American teachers and businessmen still in Iran and indeed across the Muslim world I think by the way he was probably right that if they had carried this out this would have happened
如果你这样做，会对仍留在伊朗甚至整个穆斯林世界的美国教师和商人进行大规模报复。顺便说一句，我想他可能是对的，如果他们真的执行了，这就会发生。
but nobody backs Vance up there's a very embarrassing and excruciating meeting and he's left kind of smouldering so the next evening is the six which is the moment we open the episode with. This is Beckwith meeting Jimmy Carter. And Beckwith, you would think he would absolutely despise Carter as a wimp and a weed and stuff.
但没有人支持万斯，那是一次非常尴尬和痛苦的会议，他被晾在一边生闷气。所以第二天晚上是6号，也就是我们开篇提到的时刻。这就是贝克威斯会见吉米·卡特。而贝克威斯，你会认为他绝对会鄙视卡特，觉得他是个软蛋、废物之类的。
But he clearly doesn't from that account. He thinks Carter is great. He says in his memoirs Carter was really calm, direct, forceful. He said, you know, no nonsense. Carter said, finally, okay, we'll do this. And Beckwith, in his memoirs, it says, I was full of wonderment. I was proud to be an American and to have a president. do what he'd just done. And Carter gives him that last message. If this fails, it's on me,
但从那段描述来看，他显然没有。他认为卡特很棒。他在回忆录中说，卡特非常冷静、直接、有力。他说，你知道，不废话。卡特最后说，好吧，我们做这个。贝克威斯在回忆录中写道，我充满了惊奇。我为自己是一个美国人并拥有一位能做出他刚才所做之事的总统而感到自豪。卡特给了他最后的信息。如果这失败了，责任在我，
not on you. And, you know, we don't leave any of our dead behind. And Beckwith absolutely loves this. This is music to his ears. And that's just the meeting breaks up. He says, unimprovably, he says, God bless you, Mr. President. So everybody's whipping away a manly tear. It's great. The only person who isn't, actually, I say everybody, Cyrus Vance isn't the Secretary of State. He's absolutely furious. And a couple of days afterwards, Carter, this is perhaps the other side of Carter. Carter says, I've got a load of Methodists coming to the White House. I want someone to go and tell them that we're not going to do any military action. Could you do that, please? And Vance says, no, I'm not going to lie to you to a
不在你。而且，你知道，我们不会丢下任何死者。贝克威斯绝对喜欢这个。这对他来说简直是天籁之音。会议就这样结束了。他无可挑剔地说，上帝保佑你，总统先生。所以每个人都在擦拭感动的泪水。太棒了。唯一不是这样的人，其实，我说每个人，赛勒斯·万斯不是国务卿。他非常愤怒。几天后，卡特——这也许是卡特的另一面。卡特说，我有一群卫理公会教徒要来白宫。我想要有人去告诉他们，我们不会采取任何军事行动。你能做那个吗，拜托？万斯说，不，我不会对一群
lot of Methodists. And Carter's furious. This is the first time the commander in chief has been disobeyed by one of his subordinates. And then Vance gives him an envelope and it's a handwritten note from his secretary of state, like a really important person, a handwritten note saying, I'm resigning. I'm out. As soon as that mission finishes, I'm going to wait till after the mission, but then I'm gone. You know, a bad blow for the Carter administration. Anyway, we come to the big day, Thursday the 24th of April. Carter and his aides are in the White House.
卫理公会教徒撒谎。卡特很愤怒。这是三军统帅第一次被他的下属违抗。然后万斯给了他一个信封，那是他国务卿的一封亲笔信，像是一个非常重要的人，一封亲笔信说，我辞职了。我不干了。一旦那个任务结束，我会等到任务结束后，但我就会离开。你知道，这对卡特政府是一个沉重的打击。无论如何，我们来到了大日子，4月24日星期四。卡特和他的助手们在白宫。
They're pretending that it's just an ordinary day, but this is the day that's been chosen. And at 10.30 that morning, he gets a call from General Jones. It's night in Iran. The weather is clear. It's all go, the choppers have taken off from the Nymets. Meanwhile, in Egypt, Charlie Beckwith's men, Delta Force, lining up for their final inspection
他们假装这只是普通的一天，但这正是被选中的日子。那天早上10点30分，他接到了琼斯将军的电话。伊朗那边是晚上。天气晴朗。一切准备就绪，直升机已经从尼米兹号上起飞。与此同时，在埃及，查理·贝克威斯的部下，三角洲部队，正在进行最后的检查，
in their airbase hangar. And they're all dressed kind of in plain clothes. They're all wearing jeans and kind of flannel shirts and black jackets. They haven't shaved because they want to blend in on the streets of Tehran. They've written farewell letters to their wives and girlfriends, if the worst happens. And now a scene that is so made for Hollywood.
在他们的空军基地机库里。他们都穿着便装。他们都穿着牛仔裤、法兰绒衬衫和黑色夹克。他们没有刮胡子，因为他们想融入德黑兰的街道。如果发生最坏的情况，他们已经给妻子和女朋友写了告别信。现在是一个非常适合好莱坞的场景。
In the hangar, their ops officer who's called Major Jerry Boykin has put a big sort of photo, a montage of all the hostages faces. These are the Americans that we are going to get out of Tehran. And Major Boykin gets out the Bible, and he reads from the first book of Samuel. And David put his hand in a bag and took thence a stone and slung it and smoked the Philistine in the forehead so that the stone sunk into his forehead and he fell on his face to the earth. So David prevailed over the Philistine with a stone and a stone and a stone. And a sling. He finishes and they all bow their heads in prayer. And then one of them starts singing, God bless America, and they all join in. And the sound kind of echoes around the hangar.
在机库里，他们的行动官杰里·博伊金少校放了一张大照片，是所有人质面孔的蒙太奇。这些就是我们要从德黑兰救出来的美国人。博伊金少校拿出圣经，读了撒母耳记上。大卫伸手从袋子里掏出一块石头，用机弦甩去，打中非利士人的额头，石头进入额内，他就仆倒，面伏于地。这样，大卫用机弦和石头胜了那非利士人。他读完后，他们都低头祈祷。然后其中一个人开始唱《上帝保佑美国》，他们都加入了。声音在机库里回荡。
And it's actually, I mean, the reason I did this, I think, is that this is the last scene of the film, The Deer Hunter, which had been released just over a year earlier and had been a massive hit at the Oscars. So, I mean, literally Hollywood. Literally Hollywood. And then they finish, the song dies away. And it's time to go. Operation Eagle Claw is underway. Goodness me. I mean, Dominic, what a pitch for a Hollywood thriller.
实际上，我的意思是，我想我之所以这么做，是因为这是电影《猎鹿人》的最后一幕，该片在一年前刚上映，并在奥斯卡奖上大获成功。所以，我的意思是，简直就是好莱坞。简直就是好莱坞。然后他们结束了，歌声渐渐消失。是时候出发了。鹰爪行动正在进行中。天哪。我的意思是，多米尼克，这真是好莱坞惊悚片的绝佳题材。
We will find out what happens after the break. Welcome back to The Rest is History. Massive, massive tension, massive, massive drama brewing because it's the morning of 24th of April 1980 and in the White House Jimmy Carter is waiting by his phone for news from Iran. So he knows that about midday
休息后我们将找出发生了什么。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。巨大的、巨大的紧张感，巨大的、巨大的戏剧性正在酝酿，因为现在是1980年4月24日的早晨，在白宫，吉米·卡特正守在电话旁等待来自伊朗的消息。所以他知道大约中午
the first helicopters should reach Desert One and he and his aides are looking at their watches and all these meetings but they look in their watches the whole time. And at lunchtime he's having a sandwich in the Oval Office and the Secretary of Defence, who's called Harold Brown, brings the news from Iran. And it's bad news, Tom. So the helicopters have been flying across the desert
第一批直升机应该到达沙漠一号，他和他的助手们看着手表，虽然一直在开会，但他们一直在看手表。午餐时间，他在椭圆形办公室吃三明治，国防部长哈罗德·布朗带来了来自伊朗的消息。那是坏消息，汤姆。所以直升机一直在穿越沙漠，
and they've run into an unexpected sandstorm, like a sort of dust storm, a really bad dust storm. I mean, you say unexpected, but I imagine dust storms are pretty common. I think it was bad luck. I think it was genuinely really bad luck, though. You know, you could fly across 10 times and there'd be no dust storm, but on the 11th is a dust storm,
他们遇到了意想不到的沙尘暴，就像一种沙尘暴，非常严重的沙尘暴。我的意思是，你说意想不到，但我认为沙尘暴很常见。我认为那是运气不好。不过，我认为这确实是运气非常不好。你知道，你可以飞过10次都没有沙尘暴，但第11次就是沙尘暴，
and this is the 11th time. one of the helicopters has gone down in the dust storm because the dust is so terrible it's kind of got into their rotors or whatever and they've had to abandon this helicopter the men have got out and gone into the other helicopters but they've had to abandon it a second helicopter got totally lost in the dust storm
而这是第11次。其中一架直升机在沙尘暴中坠落，因为沙尘太可怕了，它进入了他们的旋翼之类的，他们不得不放弃这架直升机，人员出来进入了其他直升机，但他们不得不放弃它。第二架直升机在沙尘暴中完全迷失了方向，
and almost crashed into a mountain and has turned back to the Gulf of Oman but so instead of having eight helicopters they now have six is that enough to get that hostages? That is enough. That is just enough. Now meanwhile, Charlie Beckwith and Delta Force have landed safely and on time at Desert 1. But here too, there are some unexpected hiccups. So first of all, as they're landing, they see two, basically two vehicles, which are oil tankers driven by Iranian smugglers, oil smugglers, streaking across the desert. And the US Rangers chased after these
差点撞上一座山，并折返往阿曼湾，所以他们现在只有6架直升机，而不是8架。这足以救出人质吗？这足够了。这刚好足够。现在与此同时，查理·贝克威斯和三角洲部队已经安全准时地降落在沙漠一号。但在这里，也有一些意想不到的波折。所以首先，当他们降落时，他们看到两辆车，基本上是两辆油罐车，由伊朗走私者、石油走私者驾驶，在沙漠中疾驰。美国游骑兵追赶这些
oil tankers, because they said, God, we can't allow anyone to have seen us. They, took one of them out with an anti-tank rocket. So the tanker kind of exploded. Whoa. And, I mean, that wasn't very discreet because they're blown up an oil tanker with a kind of missile. And the next thing that happens, suddenly this bus appears out of the night.
油罐车，因为他们说，天哪，我们不能让任何人看到我们。他们用反坦克火箭摧毁了其中一辆。所以油罐车爆炸了。哇。而且，我的意思是，那不是很谨慎，因为他们用导弹炸毁了一辆油罐车。接下来发生的事情是，突然这辆公共汽车从夜色中出现。
And the bus is packed with pilgrims, most of whom are women. Oh, no. And it's overloaded with the pilgrim's luggage. And the Rangers, this time, they fire at the tires of the bus. disable the bus and they take all these women pilgrims off as prisoners. So, I mean, we're talking about dozens and dozens of people.
公共汽车上挤满了朝圣者，其中大多数是妇女。哦，不。而且上面装满了朝圣者的行李。游骑兵这次向公共汽车的轮胎开火，使公共汽车瘫痪，并将这些女性朝圣者全部作为俘虏带走。所以，我的意思是，我们在谈论几十个几十个人。
And they're like, what are we going to do with all these women? And they put them on one of their transport planes and they say, well, we'll hold them on this transport plane at Desert 1 until the mission is over. So at midnight local time, they hear sound overhead and it's the helicopters, six of them. And they're more than an hour late. So the helicopters land. And now this sort of patch of desert is very crowded. You've got transport planes, you've got helicopters,
他们就像，我们要怎么处理这些妇女？他们把她们放在其中一架运输机上，说，好吧，我们会把她们扣留在沙漠一号的这架运输机上，直到任务结束。所以当地时间午夜，他们听到头顶有声音，那是直升机，6架。而且它们晚了一个多小时。所以直升机降落了。现在这片沙漠非常拥挤。你有运输机，你有直升机，
you've got all the blocs from Delta Force, you've got a burning wreckage of an oil tanker, you've got a captured bus, and a load of captured pilgrims, all packed into this bit of the desert. And Beckwith is horrified when he sees they've only got six helicopters. That's the bare minimum to complete the mission. And they're running out of time.
你有三角洲部队的所有人，你有油罐车的燃烧残骸，你有一辆被俘的公共汽车，还有一大批被俘的朝圣者，全部挤在这片沙漠里。当贝克威斯看到他们只有6架直升机时，他感到震惊。那是完成任务的最低限度。而且他们的时间不多了。
They have to do all this under cover of darkness. So he says to his men, okay, hurry up. Get your gear, take it from the transports, load on to the choppers. And then, as they're doing that, one of the marine pilots comes up to him and he says, Sir, we have a problem. A pump on one of the helicopters has failed. And they did bring repair equipment with them, but it was in the helicopter they abandoned in the dust storm. Oh no. Suddenly Beckwith has this massive decision to make. He could go on with a smaller team in just five helicopters, but his written instructions are very clear.
他们必须在夜色的掩护下完成所有这些。所以他对他的手下说，好吧，快点。拿上你们的装备，从运输机上拿下来，装上直升机。然后，当他们这样做时，其中一名海军陆战队飞行员走到他面前说，长官，我们有个问题。其中一架直升机上的泵坏了。他们确实带了维修设备，但它在他们在沙尘暴中放弃的那架直升机里。哦，不。突然，贝克威斯面临这个巨大的决定。他可以带着更小的团队只用5架直升机继续前进，但他的书面指示非常明确。
next to the words less than six hellos is the single word in capital letters abort now he can't make that decision himself the commander-in-chief has to make it
在“少于6架直升机”字样旁边，是一个用大写字母写的单词：中止。现在他不能自己做那个决定。三军统帅必须做出决定。
so back at the White House Carter's chief of staff Hamilton Jordan gets a call from his boss Hamilton Jordan has the bloke previously was wearing a false moustache and a wig He's taken that off
所以回到白宫，卡特的幕僚长汉密尔顿·乔丹接到了他老板的电话。汉密尔顿·乔丹之前戴着假胡子和假发。他把它摘下来了。
not anymore he's taken it off and he gets this call come to the Oval Office he goes to the Oval Office Carter is sitting in there with his head and his hands devastated. Carter says,
不再戴了，他把它摘下来了，他接到这个电话，来到椭圆形办公室。他去了椭圆形办公室，卡特坐在那里，双手抱头，悲痛欲绝。卡特说，
I've just had a call and I've given the order abort the mission. Carter has absolutely crushed all that tension, all that excitement, but he's aborted the mission. And then he says,
我刚接到一个电话，我下达了中止任务的命令。卡特完全粉碎了所有的紧张，所有的兴奋，但他中止了任务。然后他说，
well, at least there were no American casualties and no innocent Iranians hurt. And then the phone rings. And Carter picks up the phone and what color there is, which isn't much, drains from his already haggard features. And he just says,
好吧，至少没有美国人伤亡，也没有无辜的伊朗人受伤。然后电话响了。卡特拿起电话，他那本已憔悴的脸上仅存的一点血色也消失了。他只是说，
Uh-huh, uh-huh. Are there any dead? And then there's a pause and then very quietly he says, I understand. And then he puts down the phone. And what's happened? What's happened? Carter's abort order had reached Desert One.
嗯，嗯。有死人吗？然后停顿了一下，然后非常安静地说，我明白了。然后他放下电话。发生了什么？发生了什么？卡特的中止命令传到了沙漠一号。
They refueled the helicopters. They prepared to abandon ship and move out. And then one of the pilots, the pilot of the helicopter Bluebeard 3, in the darkness and in dust, as he was moving his helicopter, he clipped the wing of one of the transport planes. There was this great crack
他们给直升机加了油。他们准备弃船离开。然后其中一名飞行员，蓝胡子3号直升机的飞行员，在黑暗和尘土中，当他移动他的直升机时，他撞到了其中一架运输机的机翼。传来一声巨响，
and then basically the helicopter fell out of the sky onto the plane. There was a massive explosion and then the flames from that explosion spread to the plane's fuel supply and there was a second explosion like a fireball, colossal fireball as the plane blew up. Amazingly, only eight Americans were killed.
然后基本上直升机从空中掉到了飞机上。发生了巨大的爆炸，然后爆炸产生的火焰蔓延到飞机的燃料供应，发生了第二次爆炸，像火球一样，巨大的火球，飞机爆炸了。令人惊讶的是，只有8名美国人丧生。
Five airmen in the transport plane and three in the helicopter. And it's a scene of total devastation. There's burning wreckage everywhere, you know, smouldering bits of planes, whatever. I mean, you know, it's a shocking scene. And understandably, all the Americans say, oh my God, we've got to get the hell out of here.
运输机上有5名机组人员，直升机上有3名。这是一个完全毁灭的场景。到处都是燃烧的残骸，你知道，飞机冒烟的碎片之类的。我的意思是，你知道，这是一个令人震惊的场景。可以理解的是，所有的美国人都说，天哪，我们必须赶紧离开这里。
And they all pile into the remaining transport planes and they take off as quickly as they can. Can I just ask, do they obey Carter's orders and bring the bodies back with them? Because they're burning bodies in the middle wreckage of a transport plane. Right, because I have an incredibly vivid memory of there was a magazine called Now. Right. It was published by James Goldsmith.
他们都挤进剩下的运输机，尽可能快地起飞。我能问一下吗，他们遵守了卡特的命令并把尸体带回来了吗？因为运输机的残骸中间有燃烧的尸体。对，因为我对一本叫《现在》的杂志有非常生动的记忆。对。它是由詹姆斯·戈德史密斯出版的。
On the cover, they had a charred body of an American in the desert. And it was really vivid in my memory because it's the first time I'd seen a photograph of a body. Yeah. Really shocking image. And I was kind of wondering when I read that passage at the beginning. Was my memory playing tricks? But no. No, no, not at all.
在封面上，他们有一具美国人在沙漠里的烧焦的尸体。这在我的记忆中非常生动，因为这是我第一次看到尸体的照片。是的。非常令人震惊的图像。当我读到开头那段话时，我还在想，我的记忆是不是在跟我开玩笑？但没有。不，不，一点也不。
because actually, you know, they leave behind in the desert. You know, they've left the smoldering records of the transport and the helicopter with the bodies in them. They've left four perfectly good helicopters behind. They've left the burning remains of an Iranian oil tanker and a bus full of Iranian pilgrims who are completely baffled and frightened. By what's going on? Yeah. Yeah, by what's encouraging.
因为实际上，你知道，他们把尸体留在了沙漠里。你知道，他们留下了运输机和直升机的冒烟残骸，尸体就在里面。他们留下了四架完好无损的直升机。他们留下了伊朗油罐车的燃烧残骸和一辆装满伊朗朝圣者的公共汽车，他们完全感到困惑和害怕。发生了什么事？是的。是的，被什么鼓励了。
I mean, it must have seemed absolutely bizarre to them. They're taken prisoners by the Americans who then blow themselves up and then run away. Yeah. I mean, that's how you'd perceive it if you're an Iranian, right? And what's worse, they've left in the helicopters, their mission instructions, or the classified instructions. Why do they do that? They're leaving in the chaos and panic, right? Yeah, they think the SAS would do that.
我的意思是，这对他们来说一定显得非常离奇。他们被美国人俘虏，然后美国人炸毁了自己，然后逃跑了。是的。我的意思是，如果你是伊朗人，你就是这样看待它的，对吧？更糟糕的是，他们把任务说明或机密说明留在了直升机里。他们为什么要那样做？他们在混乱和恐慌中离开，对吧？是的，他们认为SAS会那样做。
Maybe not. So, in the Oval Office, Carter tells his team the news, and no one speaks. In fact, the only person who breaks the silence is of all people, Cyrus Vance, who's about to resign, who just says, Mr. President, I'm very, very sorry. That's decent of him. Yeah, and there's this sort of funereal mood. Of course, the truth is it was always a massive long shot, and they did a report afterwards the Pentagon, and they said, you know, plans like this,
也许不会。所以，在椭圆形办公室，卡特告诉他的团队这个消息，没有人说话。事实上，打破沉默的唯一一个人是赛勒斯·万斯，他即将辞职，他只是说，总统先生，我非常非常抱歉。他这样做很体面。是的，有一种葬礼般的气氛。当然，事实是这一直是一个巨大的赌博，他们事后做了一份报告，五角大楼，他们说，你知道，像这样的计划，
you have to prepare for the worst, and we didn't. We put our men and our machines under intolerable pressure. There was no margin for error. And actually, it turned out that the CIA had predicted, even if you get to Tehran, even if you get to the embassy, probably half the hostages will be killed in the fighting. You'll only get half of them out alive.
你必须为最坏的情况做准备，而我们没有。我们把我们的人员和机器置于无法忍受的压力之下。没有犯错的余地。事实上，事实证明，中央情报局曾预测，即使你到达德黑兰，即使你到达大使馆，可能有一半的人质会在战斗中丧生。你只能活着救出一半的人。
Do you think that there was a sense that this was a kind of Hollywood script penned by someone who saw himself as its star? I mean, I just asked because what's his name, the guy who founded the SAS. He was very much that kind of figure, wasn't he? What was he called? David Sterling. Colonel David Sterling, yeah, who later talked about carrying out a coup in 1975 from Britain against the Labour government. I just wonder whether the kind of men who have the get up and go in imagination to set up units like this, maybe their imagination can sometimes run away with them. Completely can, but that's how you have this such a unit in the first place, isn't it?
你认为有一种感觉，这是一种由把自己视为明星的人编写的好莱坞剧本吗？我的意思是，我只是问，因为那个叫什么名字的人，那个创立SAS的人。他非常像那样的人，不是吗？他叫什么名字？大卫·斯特林。大卫·斯特林上校，是的，他后来谈到1975年从英国发动政变反对工党政府。我只是想知道，那些有动力和想象力建立这样单位的人，有时他们的想象力会不会跑偏。完全可以，但这就是你首先拥有这样一个单位的原因，不是吗？
I mean, that's, I would say, an inherent part of the repertoire of such people. Yeah, an occupational hazard of it. Yeah, absolutely. That you have people who are coming up with these what seem insanely reckless ideas, but you obviously need people to rein them in and say, well, okay, well, let's look at this piece by piece, is this actually plausible? It's all going to work. Carter and Coe always knew that it was a long shot. I mean, they did it because they thought it's this or nothing. They were right, by the way, if this was the only way that they could plausibly get them out. But the press were completely unforgiving. The new republic, and a headline called it the Jimmy Carter Desert Classic. And basically
我的意思是，我会说，这是这些人剧目中固有的部分。是的，这是一种职业危害。是的，绝对。你有人提出这些看起来疯狂鲁莽的想法，但你显然需要有人来约束他们，说，好吧，好吧，让我们逐一看看，这真的可行吗？一切都会奏效。卡特和公司一直都知道这是一个赌博。我的意思是，他们这样做是因为他们认为要么这样，要么什么都没有。顺便说一句，他们是对的，如果这是他们唯一能合理救出他们的方法。但媒体完全不留情面。《新共和》杂志，标题称之为“吉米·卡特沙漠经典”。基本上
Carter got all the blame. And everyone said, look at Carter. You know, there was a time when we had the best military in the world. But now when a helicopters are in the air, they just crash. Even when they're on the they crash into each other and have to be abandoned and stuff. This is what the state that Jimmy Carter has brought us to, which is harsh, I agree, very unfair. In Iran, the reaction was unbridled delight. So there were huge crowds on the streets of Tehran. Khomeini said, this is all God's doing. You know, thanks be to God, obviously.
卡特承担了所有的责任。每个人都说，看看卡特。你知道，曾经有一段时间我们拥有世界上最好的军队。但现在当直升机在空中时，它们就坠毁了。即使在地面上，它们也会撞在一起，不得不被放弃之类的。这就是吉米·卡特带给我们的状态，这很严厉，我同意，非常不公平。在伊朗，反应是肆无忌惮的喜悦。所以德黑兰街头有大量人群。霍梅尼说，这一切都是上帝的作为。你知道，感谢上帝，显然。
And you were talking about seeing the photo on James Goldsmith's magazine. So Khomeini's chief justice, who was called Sadeh Khaqqqq. Cali, who was nicknamed the hanging judge. He went on Iranian TV to exhibit these charred remains of the bodies. Oh my God. A blackened forearm with the US military watch still on it. So he took a ghoulish delight in showing off the bodies that the Iranians had found at Desert One. Carter, he was very decent about this.
你刚才提到在詹姆斯·戈德史密斯的杂志上看到那张照片。所以霍梅尼的首席大法官，名叫萨德·哈卡利，绰号“绞刑法官”。他上了伊朗电视展示这些烧焦的尸体残骸。天哪。一只黑色的前臂，上面还戴着美国军用手表。所以他以展示伊朗人在沙漠一号发现的尸体为乐，这真是令人毛骨悚然。卡特，他在这件事上非常体面。
He took all the blame on himself. As he said he would. He wanted to ring all the families personally. but was told not to by the Pentagon. It broke a Pentagon protocol. The Secretary of Defense does it, not the president. He did fly to Delta forces based, to meet Beckwith and the team.
他把所有的责任都揽在自己身上。正如他所说的那样。他想亲自给所有的家庭打电话。但被五角大楼告知不要这样做。这打破了五角大楼的协议。国防部长做这件事，而不是总统。他确实飞往三角洲部队的基地，去见贝克威斯和团队。
A very Hollywood scene again, there's a lot of sort of manly tears and embracing and stuff. And if the American people had seen that, maybe they'd have a different view of Jimmy Carter, but as it is, they just see this bloke who yet again is coming on TV looking very pained, announcing more bad news. Loser.
又是一个非常好莱坞的场景，有很多感动的泪水和拥抱之类的。如果美国人民看到了这一点，也许他们会对吉米·卡特有不同的看法，但事实是，他们只是看到这个家伙又一次出现在电视上，看起来非常痛苦，宣布更多坏消息。失败者。
Yeah, they say he's a loser. people just say this bloke is just a born loser and seven out of ten people are saying now that it's time for a change cars is not fit to be president all of this kind of stuff so what now for the hostages they were split up and moved to prisons
是的，他们说他是个失败者。人们只是说这个家伙天生就是个失败者，现在十分之七的人说现在是改变的时候了，卡特不适合当总统，所有这些东西。那么人质现在怎么办？他们被分开并转移到监狱里，
all over Tehran and actually they disappear a little bit from the US front pages for most of the rest of 1980 there's still the business with yellow ribbons and people ringing bells and whatnot but they're not as prominent as story as they were and obviously they're a reminder of failure and defeat I suppose if they vanish into prison cells, then they're not as visible, are they?
遍布德黑兰，实际上他们在1980年剩下的时间里从美国头版上消失了一点。仍然有黄丝带和人们敲钟之类的生意，但他们不再像以前那样是一个突出的故事，显然他们是失败和挫折的提醒。我想如果他们消失在牢房里，那么他们就不那么显眼了，不是吗？
They can't be put on television, and it's a bit like the hostage situation in Lebanon in the 80s. You know, if you're not seeing them, you can forget them. Yes, out of sight out of mine, frankly. But then they returned to the headlines in October and November, not because of anything in Iran, but because of the looming presidential election. So Carter was confirmed as the Democratic candidate. Kennedy had a little bit of a revival after the desert debacle, but wasn't enough to stop Carter getting the nomination for the Democrats.
他们不能被放在电视上，这有点像80年代黎巴嫩的人质危机。你知道，如果你看不到他们，你就会忘记他们。是的，眼不见心不烦，坦率地说。但随后他们在10月和11月回到了头条新闻，不是因为伊朗的任何事情，而是因为即将到来的总统选举。所以卡特被确认为民主党候选人。肯尼迪在沙漠惨败后有一点复苏，但不足以阻止卡特获得民主党的提名。
The Republican side, Reagan is nominated, and he's now trying his best to win over blue-collar Democrats in industrial states. So basically, the kind of people who are like truck drivers or whatever, they listen to Jimmy Carter's speech about the crisis of confidence and they thought he'd gone mad. They're cross about their gasoline prices. They're very annoyed that people are burning the American flag
共和党方面，里根被提名，他现在正尽最大努力赢得工业州蓝领民主党人的支持。所以基本上，像卡车司机之类的人，他们听了吉米·卡特关于信心危机的演讲，认为他疯了。他们对汽油价格感到愤怒。他们非常恼火，因为人们在德黑兰街头焚烧美国国旗，羞辱美国，他们想要领导层的更迭。所以里根在民调中领先，但他的领先优势比人们通常记忆的要小得多。只有3%或4%左右，所以卡特仍然有希望。基本上，里根阵营的担心是，如果卡特能在10月或11月初，就在选举前把人质救回来，那将扭转局面。里根阵营的计算机已经决定，这将给他带来10%的提升，那将足以让吉米·卡特赢得选举。所以到目前为止，“十月惊奇”的概念已经成为美国政治话语的一部分了，是吗？绝对是。所以“十月惊奇”，一个将改变叙事的政变。共和党人正在散布大量关于“十月惊奇”的故事，实际上是为了试图先发制人，并说，哦，卡特要搞出个“十月惊奇”。你知道，他正在拿人质的生命玩弄政治，多么愤世嫉俗，所有这些事情。
in the streets of Tehran and humiliating the United States, and they want a change of leadership. So Reagan leads in the polls, but his lead was much smaller than is often remembered. It was only 3 or 4% or so, so Carter still had hope. And basically, the Reagan camp's fear is that if Carter can get the hostages back in October or early November, just before the election, that will swing it. The Reagan camp's computers have decided that it would give him a 10% boost, and that would be enough to win the election for Jimmy Carter. And so the notion of an October surprise by this point is part of American political discourse, is it? It is absolutely. So an October surprise, a coup that will transform the narrative. And the Republicans are planting loads of stories about an October surprise, actually, to try and preempt it, and saying, oh, Carter's going to pull out an October surprise. You know, he's playing politics with the lives of the hostages, how cynical, all this kind of thing.
在德黑兰街头羞辱美国，他们想要更换领导层。因此里根在民调中领先，但他的领先优势比人们通常记忆中的要小得多。只有3%或4%左右，所以卡特仍有希望。基本上，里根阵营担心的是，如果卡特能在10月或11月初，也就是选举前夕让人质获释，那将扭转局面。里根阵营的计算机分析认为，这会让他获得10%的支持率提升，这足以让吉米·卡特赢得选举。所以“十月惊奇”的概念在这一点上已经成为美国政治话语的一部分了，是吗？绝对是。所以“十月惊奇”，一场将改变叙事的政变。共和党人实际上散布了大量关于“十月惊奇”的故事，试图先发制人，声称，哦，卡特要搞“十月惊奇”了。你知道，他拿人质的生命玩弄政治，多么愤世嫉俗，诸如此类的事情。
Isn't the conspiracy theory, though, that actually is working the other way around and that it's the Republican, who are in contact with the government in Tehran to keep the hostages until after the election? Yeah. Is that true? Now, some of our American listeners will be waiting excitedly for this, for our analysis of this.
难道阴谋论不是反过来的吗，即共和党人与德黑兰政府联系，让人质留在那里直到选举之后？是的。那是真的吗？现在，我们的一些美国听众会兴奋地等待这个，等待我们对此的分析。
So to explain, the thesis is that Reagan's campaign manager, William Casey, who ended up running the CIA and being involved in Iran-Contra, so the Iran-Contra was, this is going to be a very simplified version, they were secretly selling arms to Iran
所以解释一下，这个论点是里根的竞选经理威廉·凯西，他最终经营了中央情报局并参与了伊朗门事件，所以伊朗门事件是，这将是一个非常简化的版本，他们秘密向伊朗出售武器，
as a sort of quid pro quo to try and get hostages out. of Lebanon, and they were also channeling the profits from the arms sales to fund the Contra right-wing fighters in Nicaragua, which had been explicitly banned by Congress. So a very complicated and murky story. Anyway, we touched on it, didn't we, in our series on Reagan? So Casey was involved in this, and the October surprise conspiracy theory is that actually Casey was involved in dealings with the Iranians long before Iran-Contra.
作为一种交换条件，试图把人质从黎巴嫩救出来，他们还把武器销售的利润输送给尼加拉瓜的右翼反政府武装，这已被国会明确禁止。所以这是一个非常复杂和阴暗的故事。无论如何，我们谈到了它，不是吗，在我们关于里根的系列节目中？所以凯西参与了这件事，而“十月惊奇”阴谋论是，实际上凯西早在伊朗门事件之前就与伊朗人有交易。
He was secretly meeting them in 1980, in Washington and Madrid, and he basically said to them. Don't release the hostages. Hold on to them until after the election. If you hold on to them until after the election, the Reagan administration will release Iran's frozen bank assets and we will organize arms shipments to you via Israel. So conspiracy theorists, I mean proper conspiracy theorists, first floated this story in 1980. But then when the Iran contra revelations came in the late 80s, people said, well, hold on, maybe these stories are actually true. And both the Senate and the House of Representatives held inquiries into this in the 1990s,
他在1980年秘密在华盛顿和马德里会见他们，他基本上对他们说：不要释放人质。把他们扣留到选举之后。如果你把他们扣留到选举之后，里根政府将释放伊朗被冻结的银行资产，我们将通过以色列组织武器运输给你们。所以阴谋论者，我的意思是真正的阴谋论者，在1980年首次提出了这个故事。但后来当80年代末出现伊朗门事件的揭露时，人们说，好吧，等等，也许这些故事是真的。参议院和众议院都在90年代对此进行了调查，
and they said it's actually not true. It's rubbish. And what's more, three different American news outlets, so Newsweek, the New Republic, and the Village Voice, and the Village Voice, you know, anti-establishment, definitely left-leaning. They all investigated this, and they said, it's Tosh, actually.
他们说这实际上不是真的。这是垃圾。而且更重要的是，三家不同的美国新闻媒体，即《新闻周刊》、《新共和》和《乡村之声》，而《乡村之声》，你知道，反建制，绝对是左倾的。他们都调查了这件事，他们说，这其实是胡说八道。
There wasn't a deal between Reagan and the Iranians. But it's never gone away. There was a book published as recently. It's 2024. Very well reviewed in The Guardian, among other places, by a guy called Craig Unger, an American journalist. And he said, no, no, no. And he found a lot of people who said maybe there was a secret deal.
里根和伊朗人之间没有达成协议。但它从未消失。最近还有一本书出版。是2024年。在《卫报》等地方评价很高，由一个叫克雷格·昂格的美国记者撰写。他说，不，不，不。他发现很多人说也许确实有秘密交易。
The issue is, I mean, there's one issue about Craig Unger. Craig Unger specialises in this kind of thing, because he wrote a lot about the bushes and the Saudi royal family. He's written loads about Trump being an FSB agent and stuff. Now, he might be right about all of those things. but I always tend to be a little bit skeptical when somebody sees conspiracies everywhere. That's a slight red flag for me. Not for some listeners, I guess.
问题是，我的意思是，关于克雷格·昂格有一个问题。克雷格·昂格专门研究这类事情，因为他写了很多关于布什家族和沙特王室的文章。他写了很多关于特朗普是FSB特工之类的文章。现在，他可能在所有这些事情上都是对的，但我总是倾向于在某人到处看到阴谋时保持一点怀疑。这对我来说是一个轻微的危险信号。对一些听众来说可能不是，我想。
They might sound being too skeptical. I think the bigger point is that I think it's irrelevant. I don't think there was any way the Iranians were going to release the hostages before the election, because they have come to see this as a duel between Khomeini and Carter. And there's actually a degree, I think, of the bully about the Iranian regime when it comes to Carter. I mean, the way that Khomeini would taunt him, you know, in interviews and say Carter is weak, he hasn't got the guts to fight us, he hasn't, all this kind of thing. There's a kind of sadistic glee to it.
他们可能听起来太怀疑了。我认为更大的重点是，我认为这无关紧要。我不认为伊朗人有任何可能在选举前释放人质，因为他们已经把这看作是霍梅尼和卡特之间的决斗。而且，当涉及到卡特时，我认为伊朗政权确实有一种欺凌者的程度。我的意思是，霍梅尼在采访中嘲弄他的方式，说卡特软弱，他没有胆量与我们战斗，他没有，所有这些事情。这有一种虐待狂般的快乐。
And I just don't see a world in which he would have released those hostages before the election. He didn't want to give Carter the satisfaction. But why is he even contemplating releasing them to Reagan? Is he not worried that Reagan will be a much more formidable and hawkish opponent? Why does he want to give Reagan, any rocket fuel for his presidency, wouldn't an impaired, politically damaged Carter winning a second term
我只是看不到一个他会在选举前释放那些人质的世界。他不想给卡特满足感。但为什么他甚至考虑把他们释放给里根？他不担心里根会是一个更强大、更强硬的对手吗？为什么他想给里根任何竞选燃料，难道一个受损的、政治上受损的卡特赢得第二个任期
be better for Iran than Reagan? I don't think the Iranians are thinking that closely about the results of the US presidential election, first of all, but also they would like to get their $8 billion in banking assets back. So, you know, I mean, $8 billion is a lot of money. Plus, after 1980,
对伊朗来说不比里根更好吗？首先，我不认为伊朗人对美国总统选举的结果考虑得那么仔细，而且他们也想拿回他们80亿美元的银行资产。所以，你知道，我的意思是，80亿美元是一大笔钱。加上1980年之后，
when they're fighting the Iran-Iraq war, the possibility of arms shipments becomes very important to them. So I think once the Iran-Iraq war has broken out, when Saddam Hussein has invaded, they're slightly, the Americans are no longer at the forefront of their mind. They probably just want to get this issue done and dust it, I think,
当他们进行两伊战争时，武器运输的可能性对他们变得非常重要。所以我认为一旦两伊战争爆发，当萨达姆·侯赛因入侵时，他们稍微，美国人不再是他们心目中的首要任务。我想他们可能只是想把这个问题解决掉，
and crack on with fighting Saddam. So anyway, let's get to the first weekend in November. So there's four days to go till election day. Carter is still hoping for a last-minute offer from the Iranians. And actually, on the Sunday, the election's on Tuesday and on the Sunday he gets one from the Iranian parliament. They say Carter's got to cancel all-American financial claims against Iran. He's got a hand over their frozen assets.
然后继续与萨达姆战斗。所以无论如何，让我们来到11月的第一个周末。距离选举日还有四天。卡特仍然希望得到伊朗人的最后一刻提议。实际上，在周日，选举在周二，周日他从伊朗议会那里得到了一个。他们说卡特必须取消所有美国对伊朗的金融索赔。他必须交出他们被冻结的资产。
He's got a hand over the shahs, millions. And he must promise never to intervene in Iranian affairs. The problem is that this proposed deal is so complicated financially. There is no way it will be done before election day. And Carter is gutted. And then the next day, the Monday, the last day, the last full day of the campaign, that is the day that marks the end
他必须交出沙阿的数百万美元。而且他必须承诺永远不干涉伊朗事务。问题是这个提议的交易在财务上太复杂了。在选举日之前是不可能完成的。卡特感到非常沮丧。然后第二天，周一，竞选的最后一天，完整的一天，那一天标志着
of 12 months in captivity for the hostages. And Carter's flying back after campaigning in Detroit to Washington, and he puts on the TV news on Air Force One on his plane, and he is absolutely horrified because all the three American networks ended their big news bulletins with montages of,
人质被囚禁了12个月。卡特在底特律竞选后飞回华盛顿，他在空军一号飞机上打开电视新闻，他感到非常震惊，因为所有三家美国电视网都在他们的大新闻简报结尾处播放了蒙太奇，
it's been 12 months for the hostages in captivity, yellow ribbons and all that. Yellow ribbons, the scenes of them are blindfolds, burning helicopters in the desert, it is the worst possible publicity. And at that point, I think some of his aides thought, we've lost this election. Because if that's what everybody is talking about, we're doomed. And they were right, because the next day, the Tuesday, Reagan won by almost 10%. He won 44 states to Carter's 6.
人质被囚禁了12个月，黄丝带等等。黄丝带，蒙着眼睛的场景，沙漠中燃烧的直升机，这是最糟糕的宣传。在那一刻，我想他的一些助手认为，我们输掉了这次选举。因为如果那是每个人都在谈论的事情，我们就完了。他们是对的，因为第二天，周二，里根以近10%的优势获胜。他赢得了44个州，卡特赢得了6个州。
It was a landslide. And you know what? This was not the end of Jimmy Carter's personal torment. Well, no, because he's still got two months left as president, hasn't he, before Reagan's inaugurated? Right, and his one big dream, you know, Carter has always been obsessed with the hostages. His one thing is, I want to be the president who welcomes them home. I want to get them home. It was the one thing I always wanted.
这是一场压倒性的胜利。你知道吗？这并不是吉米·卡特个人痛苦的终结。嗯，没有，因为他还有两个月的时间担任总统，不是吗，在里根就职之前？对，他唯一的一个大梦想，你知道，卡特一直对人质着迷。他唯一的一件事是，我想成为欢迎他们回家的总统。我想让他们回家。这是我一直想要的一件事。
So all through December and January, the State Department are negotiating this deal with the Iranians. Basically, through Algeria, which is the big intermediary, they will hand over $8 billion in frozen assets. And then, when the Iranians get the money, they'll release these hostages. The Iranians, I mean, I think there's no doubt they are toying with Carter. They are loving every minute of this because they don't sign the deal until the last full day of his presidency, Monday the 19th of January. The terms are so complicated the money has to go from the Bank of England to the central bank of Algeria
所以整个12月和1月，国务院都在与伊朗人谈判这项交易。基本上，通过阿尔及利亚这个大中间人，他们将移交80亿美元的冻结资产。然后，当伊朗人拿到钱时，他们就会释放这些人质。伊朗人，我的意思是，我认为毫无疑问他们在戏弄卡特。他们喜欢这一切的每一分钟，因为他们直到他总统任期的最后一天，1月19日星期一才签署协议。条款非常复杂，钱必须从英格兰银行转到阿尔及利亚中央银行，
and then Tehran will release the hostages. Now Carter hasn't slept for days. He's been in the Oval Office sort of obsessing over all the details of these transactions. and he says to his aides, the hostages matter more to me than anything. He's not going to have a farewell party in the White House as people normally do. There's not going to be a drinks party
然后德黑兰将释放人质。现在卡特已经好几天没睡觉了。他一直待在椭圆形办公室，沉迷于这些交易的所有细节。他对他的助手说，人质对我来说比什么都重要。他不会像人们通常做的那样在白宫举行告别派对。不会有酒会
for all the people who've worked with him because he is waiting to fly to West Germany to an air base where the hostages will be brought to go to a US military hospital. And he reckons he can just about get to West Germany, greet the hostages, and then get back to Washington for Reagan's inauguration at midday on the Tuesday.
为所有与他共事的人，因为他正在等待飞往西德的一个空军基地，人质将被带到那里去美国军事医院。他估计他勉强能赶到西德，迎接人质，然后赶回华盛顿参加周二中午里根的就职典礼。
So on Monday he's just sitting there in the Oval Office, waiting for the go ahead. And then finally they get news from Tehran. The Iranians have rejected one of the financial documents. Of course they have. And they're going to have to start the transfer all over again. You can't believe it. He's waiting and waiting. At 2 o'clock in the morning, he gets a call from the US Treasury.
周一他坐在椭圆形办公室里，等待着行动的指令。终于，他们收到了来自德黑兰的消息。伊朗人拒绝了其中一份财务文件。当然，他们会拒绝。他们必须重新开始整个转账过程。你简直不敢相信。他一直在等待。凌晨两点，他接到了美国财政部的电话。
The Iranians have now sent documents to their own, but they've sent the wrong bank code and the wrong figures. I mean, of course the Iranians are doing this deliberately, I think. Carter's aides were all to sleep on the sofa. but he's still, you know, sitting there in his cardigan, making notes in his little pad, God, hasn't slept for about a week, all of this. And finally he gets the call at 6.30 in the morning. The Bank of England have transferred the money to the Bank of Algeria, and the Algerians have sent word to Tehran.
伊朗人现在把文件发给了他们自己的人，但他们发错了银行代码和金额。我的意思是，我认为伊朗人当然是故意这样做的。卡特的助手们都睡在沙发上，但他仍然穿着开衫，坐在那里，在小本子上做着笔记。天哪，他已经大约一周没睡觉了。终于，他在凌晨6点30分接到了电话。英格兰银行已将资金转入阿尔及利亚银行，阿尔及利亚人已向德黑兰传达了消息。
You can release the hostages now. And Carter, you know, it's come too late for him to go and greet them in West Germany, but at least, you know, it's kind of happened under his watch. and he, this is my favorite detail he says to his aides, ring Ronald Reagan. Reagan is staying basically across the streets ready to take over.
你们现在可以释放人质了。卡特，你知道，他去西德迎接他们已经太晚了，但至少，你知道，这算是在他的任期内发生的。这是我最喜欢的细节，他对助手说，给罗纳德·里根打电话。里根基本上就住在街对面，准备接管政权。
He says ring Reagan, you know, the incoming president will want to know. And Reagan's aides say, oh, he's given instructions not to be, he's asleep, he's not getting on now to take you a call. He's given instructions not to get up, not to be woken until after 8 o'clock.
他说给里根打电话，你知道，新任总统会想知道的。里根的助手说，哦，他已经指示不要被打扰，他在睡觉，现在不会接你的电话。他已经指示不要起床，也不要在他8点之前叫醒他。
Carter can't believe this because this is antithetical to his way of working. Yeah, finally. Those tennis courts aren't going to book themselves. Right, exactly. Finally, what did Reagan say? They say hard work, never killed anyone, but I say, why take the chance?
卡特简直不敢相信，因为这与他的工作方式背道而驰。是的，终于。那些网球场不会自己预订。对，没错。最后，里根说了什么？他们说努力工作从未害死过任何人，但我说，为什么要冒这个险呢？
He gets through to Reagan at 8.30, and then my favorite line of this entire Iranian revolutionary story. Carter speaks to Reagan for ages, and then he puts down the phone, and his aides say, what did Reagan say? And he said, oh, how did it go? And Carter said, well, Reagan just listened. And then when I'd finished, he said, what hostages? Is that Carter making a joke? I don't know. I think it possibly is Carter making a joke.
他在8点30分打通了里根的电话，然后是整个伊朗革命故事中我最喜欢的一句台词。卡特和里根聊了很久，然后他放下电话，助手们问，里根说了什么？他说，哦，进展如何？卡特说，嗯，里根只是听着。然后当我讲完时，他说，什么人质？那是卡特在开玩笑吗？我不知道。我想这可能是卡特在开玩笑。
And if so, hats off to Jimmy Carter. That is a good joke. It is a good joke. I mean, if it's Reagan's joke, it's even funny. Anyway, the inauguration gets underway. Carter is still waiting for news. Ron and Nancy arrive at the White House, and Carter's still waiting, and they say to his aid say,
如果是这样，向吉米·卡特致敬。那是个好笑话。确实是个好笑话。我的意思是，如果是里根的笑话，那也很有趣。总之，就职典礼开始了。卡特仍在等待消息。罗恩和南希抵达白宫，卡特还在等，他们对他的助手说，
the hostages are still not, they're literally sitting on airport buses. They're not being allowed onto the planes. So he won't get the one thing he wanted, which is the chance as president. to announce that they have left Iran. He won't even get that. At midday, Reagan is inaugurated.
人质仍然没有，他们实际上正坐在机场的巴士上。他们不被允许登上飞机。所以他得不到他想要的那唯一一件事，那就是作为总统宣布他们已经离开伊朗的机会。他甚至连这个都得不到。中午，里根宣誓就职。
Carter standing next to him looks kind of like a ghost. He's so tired. In Tehran, the guards on the airport buses get the call. Basically, Reagan is in and Carter is out. And they say, fine. And they open the doors. They rip their blindfolds off the hostages. And they push the hostages out.
站在他旁边的卡特看起来像个幽灵。他太累了。在德黑兰，机场巴士上的警卫接到了电话。基本上，里根上台了，卡特下台了。他们说，好吧。然后他们打开车门。他们扯下人质的眼罩。把人质推了出去。
And the hostages are herded onto these Air Algeria planes, but there's a crowd there spitting at them and chanting death to America as they board the planes. So the Iranians had claimed, of course, that they were guests, but I have to say this is not the great moments in the history of Iranian hospitality.
人质被赶上阿尔及利亚航空的飞机，但当他们登机时，人群在向他们吐口水，高喊“打倒美国”。所以伊朗人当然声称他们是客人，但我不得不说，这并不是伊朗好客历史上的高光时刻。
So all of that meant that it was Reagan, not Carter, who got to announce their release, and he did it in the most classic Reagan Hollywood style. He gives the speech at the inauguration lunch, and he ends, he's giving a toast, and he says, and you can do it, Tom,
所以这一切意味着是里根，而不是卡特，得以宣布他们获释，而且他以最经典的好莱坞里根风格完成了这件事。他在就职午宴上发表讲话，最后他举杯祝酒，他说，你可以做到，汤姆，
because you do a very good Ronald Reagan. Oh, with thanks to all. mighty God, I have been given a tagline. The get-off line, everyone wants at the end of a speech. Some 30 minutes ago, the planes bearing our prisoners left Iranian airspace and are now free of Iran. Then he raises his champagne glass and everybody cheers at such a Hollywood moment. Carter was in his car going to Andrew's Air Force Base when he got the news. He flew eventually to Vies Barton and West Germany to greet the hostages, not as president, but as a very exhausted and gaunt ex-president.
因为你模仿罗纳德·里根模仿得非常好。哦，感谢全能的上帝，我得到了一句标语。每个人在演讲结束时都想要的那个金句。大约30分钟前，载着我们囚犯的飞机离开了伊朗领空，现在已经脱离了伊朗。然后他举起香槟杯，每个人都为这好莱坞式的时刻欢呼。卡特在前往安德鲁斯空军基地的车里收到了消息。他最终飞往西德的威斯巴登迎接人质，不是以总统的身份，而是以一位精疲力竭、面容憔悴的前总统身份。
And it was a very poignant scene. Some of the hostages, of course, they're all absolutely traumatized and exhausted. Some of them were in tears, some of them applauded him. But actually, he'd hoped for this great cathartic moment. But some of them actually say, why did you let the Shah in? Why didn't you rescue us? What was that business about the desert? What's all that about?
那是一个非常令人心酸的场景。当然，一些人质完全受到了创伤和精疲力竭。有些人流下了眼泪，有些人为他鼓掌。但实际上，他曾希望有一个伟大的宣泄时刻。但有些人实际上说，你为什么要让沙阿进来？你为什么不救我们？关于沙漠的那件事是怎么回事？那到底是怎么回事？
I mean, I guess if there's a moral to this whole thing, story, it's, don't be kind, right? I mean, don't let dying dictators into your country. Timmy Carter didn't want to let a dictator. Didn't want to let the shower in? No, I know he didn't. But he did, and everything followed from that, right? Well, I mean, we can discuss the lessons in just a sec. What did it all mean? The hostages were there for 444 days. And I think when you read interviews with them, I mean, it's the defining moment in their lives. And some of them never really recovered, I think, from the trauma of, I mean, the terror of being held in Tehran. And I imagine the physical treatment as well.
我的意思是，我想如果整个故事有一个寓意的话，那就是，不要太善良，对吧？我的意思是，不要让垂死的独裁者进入你的国家。吉米·卡特不想让独裁者进来？不想让沙阿进来？不，我知道他不想。但他还是让他进来了，随之而来的一切都发生了，对吧？嗯，我的意思是，我们稍后可以讨论这些教训。这一切意味着什么？人质在那里待了444天。我想当你阅读对他们的采访时，我的意思是，这是他们生命中的决定性时刻。我想他们中的一些人从未真正从创伤中恢复过来，我的意思是，被关在德黑兰的恐惧。我想还有身体上的折磨。
Being beaten up and starved and, yeah. People paying Russian re-elect with you or whatever, taunting you, being dragged in front of a crowd, blindfolded, all of those kinds of things. For Carter, it becomes defining, it becomes the moment that taints his presidency forever. I think in many ways a much more interesting and sort of forward-looking presidency than people remember. I mean, he's a pretty strange character by the standards of presidents, Jimmy Carter, but he's trying lots of different things and he's a definite break from the norm. But the perception of weakness. I mean, that's how subliminally I remember him as a child who was
被殴打和挨饿，是的。人们用你来竞选连任或者其他什么，嘲弄你，把你拖到人群面前，蒙上眼睛，所有这些事情。对卡特来说，这变得具有决定性，这成为永远玷污他总统任期的时刻。我认为在许多方面，这是一个比人们记忆中更有趣、更具前瞻性的总统任期。我的意思是，按照总统的标准，吉米·卡特是一个相当奇怪的人物，但他尝试了很多不同的事情，他绝对打破了常规。但那种软弱的印象。我的意思是，作为一个孩子，我潜意识里就是这样记住他的，当时我刚开始关注新闻，我只是把他看作一个失败者。
first becoming aware of the news is I just sort of him as a loser. Yeah, exactly. For Reagan and the conservative movement, it's a gift actually, this whole story because it confirms this impression of the 1970s as a decade of humiliation and retreat, that it'll take a bit of Hollywood magic to restore America's vigor. And I think the Iranian hostage crisis and the Iranian Revolution generally really mattered in the American imagination
是的，完全正确。对于里根和保守派运动来说，这实际上是一份礼物，因为整个故事证实了70年代是一个充满羞辱和退缩的十年的印象，需要一点好莱坞魔法来恢复美国的活力。我认为伊朗人质危机和伊朗革命在很大程度上确实影响了美国的想象力，
because I think it's always there in the background when other things happen in the 80s and 90s and 2000s. So Iran becomes, in the American imagination, the embodiment of sort of oriental fanaticism and cruelty And I think even though people aren't maybe consciously or directly thinking or talking about it, the scar of this is always there in 9-11, in the first Gulf War, in the invasion of Iraq, all of those kinds of things. Americans had never thought about the Middle East, I think, before this. This is the point at which sort of Islamic fanatics really start to loom as enemies of the United States.
因为我认为当80年代、90年代和2000年代发生其他事情时，它总是作为背景存在。因此，在美式想象中，伊朗成为了某种东方狂热和残忍的化身。我认为即使人们可能没有自觉地或直接地思考或谈论它，这种伤痕在9-11事件、第一次海湾战争、入侵伊拉克等所有这些事情中总是存在的。我认为在此之前，美国人从未考虑过中东。这是伊斯兰狂热分子真正开始作为美国敌人出现的时候。
Anyway, we'll end in Tehran. So we left the Iranian Revolution, really our narrative of it, in the end of 79 with Khomeini strengthening his grip. And the hostage crisis allowed him to complete that process. Because in the next couple of years, the religious conservatives really took control of Iran. Part of it was that they were able to use anti-Americanism as kind of ideological fuel.
总之，我们以德黑兰结束。所以我们把伊朗革命，也就是我们的叙述，留在了79年底，当时霍梅尼加强了他的控制。人质危机使他能够完成这一进程。因为在接下来的几年里，宗教保守派真正控制了伊朗。部分原因是他们能够利用反美主义作为一种意识形态燃料。
They got an arguably an even bigger boost in September 1980 when Saddam Hussein invaded. and the Iran-Iraq war started. But that's a terrible war for Iran, isn't it? And indeed for Iraq. It's like the First World War. Human wave attacks, trenches, gas. And it ends in a stalemate.
他们在1980年9月萨达姆·侯赛因入侵时得到了可以说更大的推动，两伊战争开始了。但这对伊朗来说是一场可怕的战争，不是吗？对伊拉克也是如此。这就像第一次世界大战。人海战术、战壕、毒气。最终以僵局告终。
Half a million people kill basically for nothing. I remember I mentioned this stay in Hamadan in Iran, where I met the old Shahs officer who'd loved the disco dancing in Chelsea. But I remember watching if there was a football match on. I think it was a British football match, English football match. and at half time instead of you know pundits coming on and analyzing v a r or whatever they showed maimed war veterans of that war kind of displaying their you know their injuries and their amputations and things and uh i mean you think i mean if that's if that's what you're
五十万人基本上白白牺牲了。我记得我提到过在伊朗哈马丹的逗留，在那里我遇到了那位热爱切尔西迪斯科舞的老沙阿军官。但我记得如果当时有足球比赛的话，我会看。我想那是一场英国足球比赛，英格兰足球比赛。在中场休息时，没有专家出来分析VAR或其他什么，而是展示了那场战争中残疾的退伍军人，展示他们的伤口和截肢之类的东西，呃，我的意思是，你认为，我的意思是，如果这就是你
getting even in sports programs yeah what a constant trauma yeah the stuff about the sort of martyrs of the Iran-Iraq war, I mean, looms so large, and certainly for Iran, sort of Iranian sensibility, and left a massive scar, I think. But of course, what it did, just as in the French or the Russian revolutions, it worked in the hardliners' favour, because doubters or moderates are seen as unpatriotic, and people start to flee the centre ground for the extremes. And that allowed Khomeini and, well, his allies, certainly, and the more hardline elements, to purge the sort of more moderate members of his coalition, some of whom were actually executed. They shut down dissenting newspapers. They executed the more left-wing element of this sort of Islamist
即使在体育节目中看到的，是的，多么持续的创伤，是的。关于两伊战争烈士的事情，我的意思是，影响非常大，当然对于伊朗，对于伊朗人的情感来说，留下了一个巨大的伤痕，我想。但当然，它所做的是，就像在法国或俄国革命中一样，它对强硬派有利，因为怀疑者或温和派被视为不爱国，人们开始从中间地带逃向极端。这使得霍梅尼和他的盟友，当然，以及更强硬的分子，能够清洗他联盟中更温和的成员，其中一些人实际上被处决了。他们关闭了持不同政见的报纸。他们处决了这种伊斯兰主义光谱中更左翼的分子。
spectrum. And they were able to push through this sort of social and cultural revolution, taking schools back into clerical control. They nationalized lots of industry. They launched all these campaigns against Western values. Most notably being the obligational women to wear hijab. But here's the interesting thing. That thing that we talked about earlier on and we've talked about before, the tension in Iran between the democratic and the Islamist elements was never resolved. So on the one hand, you know, Iran to this day, this sort of repressive, autocratic state, but it does have contested elections. You know, admittedly, you know, not everybody's allowed to run, but it's not a monolithic autocracy. And at the same time, women's rights very severely restricted, you know, what women can wear, how they look and so on.
他们能够推动这种社会和文化革命，将学校重新置于教士的控制之下。他们将许多工业国有化。他们发起了所有这些反对西方价值观的运动。最著名的是强制妇女佩戴头巾。但有趣的是这一点。我们之前谈到的那件事，我们之前也谈过，伊朗在民主和伊斯兰主义元素之间的紧张关系从未得到解决。所以一方面，你知道，伊朗直到今天，这种压迫性的、专制的国家，但它确实有竞争性的选举。你知道，诚然，你知道，不是每个人都被允许参选，但它不是一个单一的专制国家。与此同时，妇女权利受到非常严重的限制，你知道，妇女可以穿什么，她们看起来怎么样等等。
And yet, confusingly, Iran has more female engineers, university-educated engineers, than any other country per capita in the world. So it's a land of contrasts and paradoxes. Land of contrast. Well, we mentioned, they also have more gender reassignment operations than anywhere else in the world. And I guess the question, I mean, maybe we can talk about this in a bonus episode in more detail, is whether it has. had to work out as it did. Are there parallel universes in which the Iranian revolution turns out differently? And I think as with the French and Russian revolutions, the answer is yes. The Shah could have handled things differently. The Americans certainly could. They could have ditched the Shah earlier.
然而，令人困惑的是，伊朗的人均女性工程师、受过大学教育的工程师数量比世界上任何其他国家都多。所以这是一个充满对比和悖论的土地。对比的土地。嗯，我们提到了，他们的人均性别重置手术数量也比世界上任何地方都多。我想问题是，我的意思是，也许我们可以在奖励剧集中更详细地讨论这一点，它是否必须以这种方式发展。是否存在伊朗革命结果不同的平行宇宙？我认为就像法国和俄国革命一样，答案是肯定的。沙阿本可以以不同的方式处理事情。美国人当然也可以。他们本可以更早地抛弃沙阿。
They could have rushed into a military coup. They could have tried to reach out to Khomeini. Maybe he might have behaved differently. I think it's unlikely. The hostage crisis, if that hadn't happened, maybe things would have played out differently on the streets of Tehran. My last thought is, I think it's odd that of the two great 20th century revolutions, the Russian Revolution is far better known in the West. So Lenin and Stalin are far better known than the Aetala Khomeini. But I would say the Islamic Revolution in Iran is much more relevant in the 21st century than the Russian Revolution.
他们本可以冲进一场军事政变。他们本可以尝试接触霍梅尼。也许他可能会表现得不同。我认为这不太可能。人质危机，如果那没有发生，也许事情会在德黑兰街头以不同的方式发展。我的最后一个想法是，我认为奇怪的是，在20世纪的两大革命中，俄国革命在西方更为人所知。所以列宁和斯大林比阿亚图拉·霍梅尼更为人所知。但我会说，伊朗的伊斯兰革命在21世纪比俄国革命更具相关性。
Completely. Because, I mean, there aren't many communists. You don't meet many communists. And it seems unlikely to me that a major industrialized country, country will be taken over by a communist coup. But there are a lot of Islamists. What hominy pioneered, so that blend of radical modernity and kind of backward-looking conservatism, the blend of religiosity and nationalism as well, actually. And his ability to tap people's anxieties remains enormously powerful, I would say. I mean, I think that appeal to
完全正确。因为，我的意思是，没有多少共产主义者。你遇不到多少共产主义者。而且在我看来，一个主要的工业化国家被共产主义政变接管是不太可能的。但有很多伊斯兰主义者。霍梅尼开创的，那种激进现代性和某种向后看的保守主义的融合，宗教性和民族主义的融合，实际上也是。他利用人们焦虑的能力仍然非常强大，我会说。我的意思是，我认为那种诉求
nationalism is a particularly Iranian thing. The sense Iranians have of themselves as belonging to an incredibly ancient civilization, because it's true, is much more pronounced than it is in most other Muslim Arab countries, because Iran is the country that doesn't Arabis. Yes. Unlike Egypt or Syria or whatever. Agreed. But I think the style of politics, his style that he pioneered and his ability, and don't forget, Khomey was in many ways a very modern figure with his, you know, cassettes of his sermons,
民族主义是一种特别的伊朗特质。伊朗人认为自己属于一个极其古老的文明，因为这是事实，这种感觉比大多数其他穆斯林阿拉伯国家要强烈得多，因为伊朗是一个不阿拉伯化的国家。是的。不像埃及或叙利亚或其他什么。同意。但我认为政治风格，他开创的风格和他的能力，别忘了，霍梅尼在许多方面是一个非常现代的人物，他有他的布道磁带，
with his message being broadcast from Paris, all of this kind of thing. and I think that that's been much more influential in the 21st century than anything that the Russian communists ever did. Anyway, next time, something completely different. The fall of Carthage. Exciting. Hannibal, the Romans, Battle of Zama. Plunging right back in time. And it will end with the destruction of the city that was, in the opinion of the Romans, their greatest and most dangerous enemy.
他的信息从巴黎广播出来，所有这些事情。我认为这在21世纪比俄国共产党人所做的任何事情都更有影响力。总之，下次，完全不同的东西。迦太基的陷落。令人兴奋。汉尼拔，罗马人，扎马战役。直接回到过去。它将以罗马人认为他们最伟大、最危险的敌人的城市的毁灭而告终。
So that will be the fall of Carthage. Good news for Restis History Club members, Tom, isn't it? There is. They will get all four episodes of that Carthage series on Monday. And if you want to join them, just sign up at the Restis History.com. It's what Jimmy Carter would have wanted. Yeah. I'm not sure that's necessarily a commendation.
所以那将是迦太基的陷落。这对“历史俱乐部”的成员来说是个好消息，汤姆，不是吗？是的。他们将在周一获得那部迦太基系列的所有四集。如果你想加入他们，只需在RestisHistory.com注册。这是吉米·卡特想要的。是的。我不确定这是否一定是赞美。
Right. Join Jimmy Carter at the Restis History Club. Yeah. The whole website would probably crash. And that's hard. because I, you know, I'm left with a soft spot for Jimmy Carter. Oh. A decent man.
对。加入吉米·卡特在历史俱乐部。是的。整个网站可能会崩溃。这很难。因为我，你知道，我对吉米·卡特情有独钟。哦。一个正派的人。
Yeah, he was in many ways. Apart from getting Cyrus fans to light of the Methodists. That was very poor. Yeah. Anyway, on that note, thank you very much for listening. Thank you, Dominic, for a wonderful and timely series. Bye-bye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，他在许多方面都是。除了让赛勒斯·万斯去点亮卫理公会教徒。那真的很糟糕。是的。总之，说到这里，非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢你，多米尼克，带来了一个精彩且及时的系列节目。再见。再见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。